Okay, we're swapped now.
I couldn't find the screen.
You baited?
You baited!
I couldn't find the screen!
She's baiting again.
Anyway, welcome.
We're TSM.
Hey guys, new TSM team here.
They just signed us up, guys.
Because last time, TSM got like 17th place.
So they called us out to replace them.
Yeah, we gave them the boot.
Yeah, it is what it is.
We got the boot.
This is how it's gonna be now.
We're gonna go to LGS.
Hell yeah.
We're gonna go to World Cup!
Yeah, that's what it's called.
World Cup!
That's what they call it.
Yeah!
Let's go!
World Cup!
Yeah!
I'm gonna be goalkeeper!
Oh my god.
Guys, guys.
Okay, so RPR is gonna carry us.
And he's gonna be on Bloodhound.
No, I'm not gonna be on Bloodhound.
I'm probably gonna play Wraith.
So we can win.
Wait, what do we play then?
We need a Bloodhound.
I'm gonna play Bloodhound.
Okay, I can play Bloodhound too.
How about we play Lifeline Bloodhound?
Oh shit!
We're going European comp?
Yeah, so we can one live, two port, and three shield.
Okay, I'll be Lifeline.
I'll be Lifeline.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ditto's gonna be our controller player.
Oh yeah.
Oy vey.
It's just scrims.
It's not even the real tournament.
Scrims that we didn't even know where we landed two minutes before you started.
You're the one that gave me the landing spot!
You asked me to give you landing spots.
And then you said, no, two landing spots are not enough.
You need to give me ten for each map.
I wasn't the one that made the rules for this.
They were like, you have to list like ten.
Okay, they wanted more.
I shortened it because I was like, I'm not fucking asking.
I'm not fucking asking RPR for ten landing spots.
It was like eight.
I don't even know ten landing spots on the map.
I was like, give me top five.
You know what they asked for me?
They said give us eight.
And I was like, I'm just gonna give them five.
I barely know five.
Remember when you asked me, I was like, oh shit.
What the fuck is this?
This is more prep than ALGS.
Okay, to be fair, they also wanted me to be there at ten AM to see who was gonna get the landing spots.
But I was like, I don't wanna wake up at ten, man.
Ten AM?
I don't even wake up for ALGS at that time.
They were like, okay, you can...
Okay, but to be fair, to everybody, it's like, oh, you can't make it to ten AM.
Just let us know in advance.
And I was like, oh, thank God.
I don't have to wake up at ten in the morning to figure out where the fuck we're landing.
Wait, how are...
Doki, how are we the laziest team in the fucking lobby, but we got the best landing spots?
To make it sense.
We're just that lucky.
We got siphon and barometer.
Okay.
If we get fucking absolutely fucked over with the best landing spots, this is RPR's fault.
How is it like... okay, listen.
Because you're the one that chose those landing spots.
You chose these landing spots.
Okay, now is it my fault?
I gave us the best possible conditions.
I gave us the best possible conditions to win.
Yeah, but if we don't win, then it's IGL's fault.
Deep does IGLing?
No, you said IGL can never be on Bloodhound.
Why?
Why me?
Yeah, she can't be.
She's on Bloodhound.
Because I'm tired of being wrong.
I don't want to be voted all the time.
You are being right!
Someone else take the fault for once.
Well, then someone else be IGL.
Not me.
You have to be IGL because you're ALGS champion.
Yeah, you're ALGS champion.
Exactly.
Oh no, I was cursed with such a high IQ.
Holy shit.
Such a high IQ, but yeah, you don't win this scrim.
I don't know.
I am not at fault for my teammates actions.
Yes, you are.
It's always the IGL's fault.
That is not how this shit works.
That is 100% how it works.
You control your character.
I've seen competitive Apex on Reddit.
That's exactly how it works.
Reddit hates me, by the way.
They think I do nothing for my team.
But they're right.
They're normies.
Normies are always right.
Yeah, that's like me watching football once a week for the next three years and being like, Yeah, no, he should have went left.
And then he should have kicked the ball to the right.
And then he should have won the game.
And he's right.
You're right.
Listen, it's simple.
Apex is simple.
Kill everyone, win the game.
What if you don't kill everyone?
Ditto, can you kill everybody?
Then you lose.
Maybe if...
If Aphia don't die first.
Ditto, what is your stream title?
Ditto, Ditto, Ditto, swap, swap.
No!
Oh my, Magite.
Don't worry.
It's okay, it's okay.
We both have life.
Okay, I guess I'm on Bloodhound.
I guess.
Also, Sound Guy, I turned down RPR and turned up Ditto.
Let me know if it's better now.
How the fuck is this my fault?
This is your fault because IGL should have been the one that yelled Ditto!
Not me!
You are the IGL.
You have to tell me to shoot the Kaido, okay?
Yes!
Thank Jesus.
Thank you.
I might have to mute both of you guys for this tournament so we can win.
They knew.
They picked the wrong characters.
What did I sign up for?
This is all...
You said yes.
You said yes, yeah.
That was the first mistake number one.
Don't worry, we'll be fine.
We'll be okay.
You see, Chad doesn't know what TSM stands for.
It's TSM.
We got signed, guys.
We're on TSM now.
Can Chad guess what TSM stands for?
Because our TSM is a little bit different than Team Clones.
We're copyright free.
We're like TSM on Wish.
It's okay, guys.
I believe in us to get top five.
Because there's like, you know, there's like not even a full fucking roster here.
Dude, I was built for this shit.
Bullying VTubers in costumes?
That's my whole fucking career.
It's what I do.
Yeah, because you couldn't bully pro players anymore.
I literally want champs.
Like, what do you want?
You have to bully VTubers to feel good about yourself.
Yeah.
Yeah, fuck them VTubers.
It's fucked up.
Okay,
yeah, bring Ditto up a little bit more on Discord.
Now you're at 190.
You guys are?
SM stands for Team So Mad.
Because that's what I'm gonna be on a game.
HAHAHA.
Team So Mad.
Team So Mad, that's us.
Yeah, who's gonna be mad?
Ditto and I are gonna have fun.
Yeah.
Cause we're all good friends.
Everybody.
Friendship and positivity.
PMA.
You always need that one guy in the group that you piss off because it's funny.
And I maintain my positive mental attitude through this.
PMA guys!
Keep it up!
See?
He loves it here guys!
He loves it here.
Where's the gun?
You can say he's a little M because he likes it.
You went too far.
There's a line you cannot cross.
And you crossed it.
What do you mean?
What's the line?
If there was a line you would have said no.
I'm tired of this slander.
You wouldn't even be here.
I can't take this shit no more.
I'm actually going to become Menhera.
This is crazy.
Wait, you're not already?
I'm on my way.
I'm not fucking Tsun.
Is he a Menhera?
I'm on my way.
Yeah, me too.
I think so too.
If I am Menhera then he invented Menhera.
Can you say the beauty of Menhera?
He is what?
Menhera.
And he said he likes Menhera.
Okay, I said a little bit of Menhera is okay.
Me and Yuris both agree that 30% Menhera is okay.
Wait, what is considered 30%?
How would you know if somebody is 30%?
Okay, but what is 30%?
How can you tell if somebody is 30% Menhera?
Whatever they are is like 31%.
Well, okay, so here's the scale.
If they are at 100%, then you're going to die.
If they are at 30%, you're just going to have a little bit of like a little bit of a thriller action in your life.
Like a little bit of thrill every now and then.
What's a thrill?
Like what's the...
Oh, so I will scare for your life every now and then.
You know, like...
Like a little action, you know?
It sounds like you speak from experience.
Like he's at the 30% Menhera.
No, I wouldn't know.
I wouldn't know.
Okay, but like what tips it over the edge?
What makes it a 31% Menhera versus a 30%?
Wait, but then getting stabbed...
But 100% you die, so like...
Not every stabbing equals in death.
You know that.
How can you know?
When you get stabbed in your leg.
Well, you can have blood just pour out.
What do you get an infection?
What if you get like...
What if it's like a rusty knife?
But that's...
Then that's...
That's over 30% then.
That's too far.
But like, you didn't know...
You don't like...
What if it was an accident, you know?
Like she was just going over to clean the knife because it was getting rusty.
She was going to unrest it.
She tripped and then the knife...
She stabbed you in the leg?
Yeah, she tripped and then...
Yeah, but that's not Menhera.
That's an accident.
Menhera is like...
Yeah, but the Menhera part is that she's carrying a rusty knife around.
She was going to go clean it though.
Yeah, but the same part was to just throw it away.
So she threw it away to me?
Yeah.
Oh, hey, okay.
We got where we land.
Okay.
I'll go this side.
I'm sure chat agrees with me and that's all I need.
Wait, is that siphon?
Okay, this is siphon.
It's been a while, guys.
Listen, I'm going to go...
I'm going to go far.
I'm going to go all the way.
Why are you going all the way away from us?
No one's going to contest us.
He hates us, Ditto.
He hates us.
He doesn't want to be near us.
No, this is for efficiency.
He hates us.
Okay.
Okay, I understand.
I see.
That's sad.
Yeah.
Do you think we're Menheras?
I think he hates us.
You guys are yandere.
That's where the fuck you are.
We are not.
Yeah, how?
We are yandere.
Yeah.
How?
I have never killed anyone.
What is it?
Like, you know how.
No, I don't.
What?
Like...
If I knew, I wouldn't ask.
You don't need to explain myself.
Stop the cap.
Oh, man.
Oh, boy.
Oh, what did I say?
I think Ditto and I are perfectly normal girls.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
We're so normal.
Right, Ditto?
Yeah.
Nothing but normalcy.
We're normal.
These parts.
I think you're the freak here.
If I make a poll right now, people will think you're the freak.
No, I think Chad probably agrees.
He agrees with me.
Like, they probably say that 30% Menhera is an adequate amount of Menhera.
We're not talking about that.
I'm talking about a poll of whether or not you're more Menhera than us.
Oh, no.
Chad knows I'm the only sane person in this Discord.
You want to bet?
How much?
I don't have money.
Like, you're going to make a poor streamer?
You're going to steal money from a poor streamer?
Yes.
To prove a point.
You're a psychopath.
No, I'm not a psychopath.
I just proved my point.
I'm here to prove a point that you are wrong.
I am correctness.
You are correctness.
Okay.
I need that.
I am correctness.
I'm going to need that.
Nice.
What's the zone looking like?
I feel like a scope.
I don't know, IGL.
What is the zone?
I mean, we have the... we could have a people's ring here.
Okay.
Yeah, we don't...
Okay, we do.
I will scan the...
Okay.
Yeah, scan the ring.
Yeah, go hit the bacon.
Hit the bacon.
Okay.
Oh, we all have purple.
I have Mozambique Spitfire.
This is not very cash money.
IGL, why can't you find better guns, IGL?
I'm going to drop this Mozambique and take the Sentinel and bully this entire lobby.
Okay.
What are you going to die?
I don't die.
It doesn't happen to me.
Okay.
What happened in the last ALGS you were playing?
I was playing...
I tried to...
Then I died because of that.
Okay, where do we go?
We need... we need old charger.
We need the army.
You take the Evo.
Ditto takes the Evo and then he goes zone.
Okay, we're in zone.
Okay.
And now I take this Evo.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
We're going to head to RPR.
You press the M on your map, on your fucking keyboard.
Yeah, you press M.
Yeah.
And you open map and there's a big circle and we go in the middle of the big circle.
Oh, okay.
That's how it works.
I mean, a real Aisya would know exactly where the end zone is, but okay.
No one can read the ring one!
No one!
No Jesus on this planet!
Zero can!
No, he can't.
He's just lying.
Zero can!
He always gets the end zone correct.
Yeah, of ring two, of course he does.
No, he gets it right on ring one!
He's like a savant!
He does not!
Okay, well Zero's cheating!
Like what do you want from me?
I don't cheat!
I play fair and square.
Fair and square.
Yeah, that's why you just pull your V2, Rouge, now.
Yeah.
Exactly.
You hear it here, folks?
Our PR says Zero's cheating.
He is.
Do I do a fighting?
Do I get the revive or the reduced tactical?
Revive.
Okay.
So if we go down, we go up 20% faster.
Alright.
And then the next one, you should probably get the package so we get good stuff.
Someone's aiming at me.
I'm about to murder them.
Where should we go next?
Whoa!
I got shot at!
Whoa, whoa, we got shot!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
70 blown catalyst.
Where the fuck are they going, huh?
Okay, I'm gonna port us up the hill.
Okay, we'll wait.
Are they looking at us?
Yeah.
Yes, they are, but...
...the gaffers are useless.
Whoa!
Oh, good.
I got the port.
Don't die.
I didn't die, guys.
I only have one bat.
Good job.
Wait, did us not near the port?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Who do they think they are, huh?
I don't know, but they...
I got sand on my hands.
If they kill us, we're fucked.
I did more damage to them than they did to us.
Let's go.
I lost my only bat.
Oh, there's a team on the right.
There's a team on the right.
Oh, yeah.
Close, close, close.
Flash, flash, flash, nice.
I knocked one.
Bangalore 70.
Nice, nice.
Push left, push left, push left.
I hear people, like...
Just keep pushing downhill.
Keep pushing downhill.
I'm walking up there.
Because they're going to get sandwiched, so we got to keep pushing downhill.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm pushing, I'm pushing, I'm pushing.
And honestly, kill these motherfuckers.
Who the fuck do they think they are?
I killed one guy.
Yeah, who are they?
Yeah, yeah, kill the rest of these motherfuckers.
Yeah!
Yeah, fuck this Bangalore.
Yeah, we're TSM.
He's low, he's low, he's low, he's low.
Get him, Dito.
Get him.
Yeah, get his ass.
Yeah!
Yeah, fuck him up!
Motherfuckers.
Yeah, do a finisher.
Do a finisher.
Do a do do do do do do do do it.
I'm going to rip it.
I'm going to rip the whole thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we're going to watch.
We're going to watch.
Yeah, fuck VTubers.
What are you doing in this VTuber Apex tournament?
Oh, hey, I need a juice.
Oh my god, they got juice.
I want, I want energy, energy armor.
I got nothing.
I'll give you, I'll give you 60.
I'll give you 60 and then I switch to Bloodline.
I didn't get Q.
Someone's looking at us.
I don't know, maybe a teammate.
Where are we going by the way?
I don't know, but I'm finishing the kill.
There's a kill to finish.
Oh, there he is.
Can I use TK?
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's go home guys.
Now we got to move.
It is...
Oh my god.
This zone is ass.
I need...
Oh, I have a care package that I can call.
Should I call it or wait until I get purple?
No, let's get to like a better spot.
There's a lot of motherfuckers around us.
Yeah.
And I'm not vibing with it.
I'm not vibing with it.
Oh, we got scanned on Epi.
And then I don't think those guys are going to fuck with us.
Yeah.
They know who we are.
No, I mean, we're not even in their trajectory.
Oh.
Yeah.
No, no.
They know who we are.
Yeah.
They have walls.
They can see our names.
I think this is like...
Oh fuck.
This is this zone right here.
Absolute asshole of a zone.
I have read a player.
If you want to use it.
Honestly, yeah, I don't want to walk.
Right here?
Yep.
Right here.
All right.
Guys, he's AFK.
Shoot him.
It was all a bait.
I knew the streams that I think.
Wait, none of you guys have redeploy?
I have mobile respawn so we can get D top when she dies.
All right.
Who's going to die first?
I have help for you too.
Yeah.
You can both have.
You got me covered.
I got you covered.
This is so good.
Wait.
Okay, wait.
What about me?
No, we're good.
You don't die.
She don't die.
Don't you?
I don't die.
Okay.
Yeah.
See, somebody believes in me.
Liferay never dies.
Wait.
I try it.
When do I use my package?
I do.
I'll just use it here.
We're cool.
We're cool here.
Okay.
I'm going to charge my Sentinel.
Now the real game has started.
All right.
About to create for everyone.
Oh, sniper mag.
This package...
Alright, let's get to Joan.
Alright, we're right behind you.
If I read this wrong, it's Zero's fault.
It's Zero's fault!
It wasn't Zero's fault!
I watch him for zone predictions.
You watch him for zone.
Yeah, so if this is wrong, this is his fault.
Yeah, it's Zero.
Oh my god, okay, did it just fucking go into all the batteries?
People here?
You made it?
I have two.
Let's get in this building, we want this building.
Okay, I'll give you two.
Wow, nobody.
Nobody, because they can't read zones!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They can't read zones like our player Zero.
Thank god Zero is here for us.
Yep, he's such a good guy.
I mean, man, we love DZ.
I cracked that catalyst.
I'm gonna bully that team until they have no more meds.
Wait, I need to turn up Ditto more on my Discord, give me a sec.
I'm AFKing.
No fun, no fun.
I turned Ditto up to 200.
I can't go on.
I cracked two.
She's lying on Discord.
Wait, there's people here on me.
They're purple.
Yeah, this guy's up top as well.
Wait, how are they purple?
They're cheating.
Almost got killed.
Another one.
Wait, they have purple and we don't?
Yeah.
Why are you almost dead?
Explain yourself.
Because I got shot by three fucking people, I explained.
Okay, valid.
Like, oh, why would you get shot by three people?
Oh, Ditto, how did you get shot at, huh?
Like, four team, four team.
Yeah, exactly.
Why is that motherfucker shooting at me?
Hello?
Ooh, nice.
See, there's like extra...
Ooh, nice, there's a barrel stablizer.
Wait, Sentinel was such a good choice.
Can bully everyone now.
Yeah.
Yeah, keep peeking.
See what happens to your head.
Why are you top strafing?
Bro, he wants to show people his movement.
I'm not.
I just hit you on the head, you dumbass head.
Yeah, I was gonna be like, what the fuck?
Why are you walking here?
I wanna be part of the team.
Yeah, now my bullet's part of your head.
I wanna contribute to society.
Oh my God, he's flesh.
Oh yeah, that guy got fucking doinked.
I wish you can like farm armors again.
Wait, wait, RP, you should try and get the... get that for us.
He's dead.
Yeah, yeah, I mean, I could port for it, but I could... I mean, who's gonna kill?
Yeah, who's gonna kill you?
That guy might.
Motherfucker.
Okay, I'm not gonna peek anymore.
They have four shields.
I'm about to go crazy.
Wait, you're actually going for it?
You're throwing.
Of course I am.
You're fucking throwing.
What do you mean I'm throwing?
This is juice.
My shield's throwing.
Only one there.
It's free juice.
Oh shit, purple.
I knew that was a good... you're welcome.
I just...
I thought I told you to use that idea.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, whatever.
You're fucking wrong.
You literally just told me I was throwing.
No, I didn't.
Where's your proof?
Can that guy stop looking at me?
He keeps giving me those alerts.
You're being...
Aim it.
I don't care I'm being aimed at.
What are you looking at here, man?
Fucking mower.
Okay, I have three shield cells left.
Guys.
What the fuck are you doing?
I wanna continue.
No more peeking for you.
But I wanna peek.
It's not fair.
They're shooting at me.
100.
It's not fair.
Oh, wait.
What's this package?
Oh, a package!
Whoa!
Who wants that?
I do.
I want it.
Where's our portal?
It's outside our building.
Like, you can just jump for this one.
What if I die?
You're not gonna die.
There's no one there.
You're chilling.
But what if I die?
You wouldn't trust me.
There is no one there.
There is gonna be no death involved.
Alright, I'm gonna throw my prowler.
Alright, I'm going for it.
Holy shit, your prowler was juicy.
Yeah, it was.
Okay, I'm going for it.
There's gonna be no death involved, unless you die.
I'm going for it, I'm going for it, I'm going for it.
I gotta get us to the next spot.
I got a dead slide.
Okay, we're gonna go there now.
Why is this guy looking at me?
I have a purple barrel stabilizer, does anyone want it?
No, I'm just gonna go there and secure this spot.
Okay.
Here's a...
Oh, I got the next lifeline package.
And we're gonna keep going forward.
I knocked one.
What do you mean you knocked one?
You cracked someone.
Stop knocking people.
I... I thirsted him.
She keeps knocking people.
Like, what the fuck.
Alright, next spot.
We're going to the next spot.
Hey guys, I have...
Yeah, it's my fault that you're lying.
I'm getting pushed, I'm getting pushed.
Wait, wait, come back in, come back to our side.
I almost killed two of them.
Come back, come back, come back.
I have a phoenix kit for you.
We need to stop these motherfuckers.
We're taking our house.
We gotta kill these motherfuckers.
I cracked them though.
This is disrespectful behavior.
They took it, they had catalyst.
Kill them now!
They catalysted.
I'm not gonna play anymore unless we kill these guys.
Okay, go, go, go.
You go first.
Okay.
Wait, are we actually doing it?
Wait, I'm getting shot.
Are we doing it?
Yeah, as soon as I...
I have no shield cells, guys.
You guys have extra shield cells.
Oh, okay, nice.
See, I told you we shouldn't have gone for it.
What is that wall?
Does anyone have extra shield cells?
I only have bats.
Who the fuck plays Newcastle?
Are you guys okay in the head?
I have G.
I can give you one.
Yeah, I'll give you a bat for it.
Nice.
Ow, dumbass.
I'm gonna go above.
Okay.
So I can get a better angle.
I'm gonna look over here.
I'm gonna put us probably over there.
Guys, we're not even top 10.
Why aren't we top 10?
Because people are not dying faster than we are.
Wait for the main thing.
Tell them to die faster.
I'm actually working on it.
I was about to eliminate that team, but you guys didn't come.
I did.
I was like, I'm ready.
I'm not.
Oh, they're fighting on here.
Murder, murder.
I got murder on my mind.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Down here, down here.
I'm straight beaming.
I'm coming over.
I got 15% and I'm about to start porting us to a better spot.
These motherfuckers over here cannot take our spot.
I will fight them to death.
Wait, I'm getting shot at.
How dare he?
I have no cells.
Up here.
5%, 3%.
Where are you?
Here, 3 cells.
Stop peeking.
I'm going to peek because I have a bat.
I gave you a bat as well.
We need to go and I'm going to get us to the spot that we need to go to.
We're so poor.
Get it up here.
He's so low.
Kill him, kill him, kill him.
On me.
Take the port, take the port.
I'm taking the port.
I'm in the port.
We play here.
We play safety here.
This corner.
We're going to get pushed from there.
And everywhere.
I have a package.
I'll put a package right here.
Put a package for cover.
Perfect.
I'm charging my sentinel even though we don't have cells.
Even though we don't have cells, I'm charging my sentinel.
I don't give a fuck.
I have more bats for us.
Here guys, guys.
Take this, take that.
Take the evil cache.
I'm going to scan.
Take the evil cache guys.
I'll take it.
I took it.
Look at that.
Why did you take it?
Because I'm lifeline.
I don't need it.
I'm lifeline.
I don't need the work.
I knocked him on the roof.
There's no way we can finish him.
I think they're going to find each other.
They're going to come.
There's people behind us by the way.
I missed.
I'm looking at the team behind us.
Holy shit.
It's bugged.
The game is bugged.
There's no way I missed this much.
There's team here too.
I'm ready to left.
I think they're on the other side of the wall.
There's teams here too.
I hear them on the wall.
Whoa.
I'm batting.
Holy shit.
There's a lot of people on our right here.
I knocked one.
Everyone stay away from my area.
Okay, I'm sorry.
I'm scared guys.
We're going to kill everyone.
They're dying.
Chill.
Take it easy.
Don't be queasy.
Right on me.
Nice.
I'm batting.
There's more fighting down here.
They killed the team.
Behind us.
Here.
We need to focus this team.
No, this team on the north-east.
Yeah, Ditto.
Be careful.
There's three of them.
Who are you fighting, Ducky?
People behind us.
He's dead.
I'm looking at Ditto.
Ditto's got the right idea.
I'm here.
Crack one.
I'm dead.
Oh my god.
I'm the motherfucking best.
Dead.
All dead.
Fuck VTubers.
I'm batting.
Guys, this might be the most chaotic game.
And I have no idea what's going on.
They're fighting.
They're fighting each other.
Let them fight.
Don't let them know that we exist.
Okay.
We don't exist right now.
Can I poke?
I'm poking.
They're so low though.
Oh my god.
Kill everyone.
This is so exciting.
I kept one.
I'm so pumped right now.
Guys, we're doing it.
This is so chaotic.
Why are you shooting at me?
Focus on the guy in your building.
I am batting.
There's one team below, one team above.
And me getting an angle right now.
And murdering.
I'm healing.
Fuck this guy's door.
If you have a nade, fuck this guy's door.
Okay.
I'm gonna do it.
Do it.
Fuck his door.
Fuck this door.
Get door, fuck idiot.
I don't have nades anymore, guys.
I missed.
He's shooting.
Oh no.
88.
I'm lucky.
Kill that bull.
Oh, they're fucking each other.
Yeah.
They're rezzing.
They're rezzing with gold knock.
Throw nades.
Throw nades at them.
I don't have nades.
Why are you pushing so close?
Because I'm crazy.
You're crazy.
I love it.
That's good.
He goes to Asta.
Yeah.
He's won.
TSM.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
What is like a TSM copypasta?
That's right.
We're replacing Hal.
Do I have like 200 things?
Damn.
We're just better.
I did fuck all that game.
I wasn't even playing.
I was barely there.
Told you.
We don't...
We're so good.
We're going to be rezzing.
Yeah.
It's just it's over.
We know how this game is going to go.
Yeah.
I mean honestly like...
Oh wait.
Team Slyly Manjaro.
That's our name.
Team Slyly.
Hahaha.
We're team Slyly Manjaro.
Yeah.
Honestly I vote for that.
Team Slyly Manjaro.
Because this game is going to put me in an early blow.
I'm going to name myself Imperial RPR.
Imperial RPR.
Oh my god.
I'll name myself Doki Reps.
And then...
Just be Depps.
And their host.
Hahaha.
Their host.
It's over for everyone in this lobby.
TSM is here.
We're reppi... Oh my god.
Depps.
We had 13 kills.
How did we get 13 kills?
I feel like we did nothing all day.
To be fair I don't know what we were doing.
I was so confused this entire game.
I only shoot and straight.
Yeah.
We're just shooting.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
I'm Depps.
Let's go.
Their host.
Imperial RPR.
Hahaha.
We're back.
TSM is back guys.
Hahaha.
We're going to win the trophy.
TSM on top.
On god.
Hahaha.
Hey.
I told you.
I didn't watch Zero's watch.
Yeah.
I see.
You know I dedicate this win to Zero.
Oh my god.
Like he didn't have enough.
Hahaha.
He needs it.
He needs a third trophy.
Give him another one.
He was so sad.
See how sad he was.
It made me feel so bad when he didn't win.
Hahaha.
Yeah but like RC won.
And Ditto is on RC.
Oh true.
Ditto is on RC.
So we have world champion in our team.
We can't lose this tournament.
Oh my god.
We have TSM, RC, and Dark Zero on our team.
Holy shit.
Yeah.
Dark Zero is RPR.
I'm TSM.
And then Ditto is RC.
We literally have the full championship lobby.
Hahaha.
It's over.
We have so many trophies.
It's over for everybody.
They should just uninstall right now.
Just end the scrims early.
We can already see how it's going to end.
I've trolled this entire game.
And we won.
Hahaha.
Bro you did a fucking finisher.
I've been playing Flatline, Sentinel.
Hahaha.
Ditto and I were so confused.
That last fight.
Like in the fight right before the last fight.
I jumped in and no scoped the revenant for 88.
I think like all three of us were fighting different teams.
Hahaha.
We were all fighting different teams during the last fight.
This is the most unserious I've ever been in my life.
Like what's going to happen next?
Hahaha.
We're going to do serious shit.
To be fair, the full lobby might be a bit more serious.
Hahaha.
I was just no scoping people.
I was trolling so hard.
Like who the fuck plays Flatline Sentinel?
Hahaha.
It's you.
You're metacrafting.
I'm frontlining with a sentinel.
I'm porting in no scoping people.
Hahaha.
This is the strat guys.
If you're not doing that shit, you're not winning LAN.
Exactly guys.
Guys, this is it.
That's what RC did.
RC brought a sentinel in.
Right Ditto?
Yes.
Ditto, give us some RC strats.
How did they do it?
How did they win LAN?
Because...
Because I'm the fourth player.
Hahaha.
The fourth player?
Should they cheat it?
Are you watching?
Destroyer?
Are you Destroyer?
Actually, I won with TN Clash and we got champion.
Oh, that's true.
This is it.
Fourth player, no way.
We might actually lose a few games to not show them our true power.
That's true.
Hahaha.
And then we fuck them up on Saturday.
We should have asked who did we...
Who got finished by ARVR?
Hahaha.
How did you finish?
Yeah, who did we finish anyway?
Hahaha.
I wonder if anybody's gonna...
Oh, it was...
In the...
What was it?
In the city.
Oh.
Hahaha.
Oh, they're both...
Oh yeah, they're both cities.
I guess we'll never know.
They're too embarrassed to admit it.
Who's even the best team?
The second best team.
I guess like the... Team 3?
Team 3 has 10 kills.
Who's in Team 3?
Team 3.
This person is not gonna admit I finished him.
Come on!
Give me the juice!
Chad!
Stream snipe for us!
Ghost for us!
Who was it?
There's no stream tonight.
I wish it wasn't me.
Hahaha.
This person said, I wish it was me.
Someone said it was Nia's team.
Hahaha.
That's why she's not speaking up.
She's not gonna give me the win.
Hahaha.
Just look at her vibe.
There's no stream delay.
Hahaha.
Did I finish Nia exactly?
Dude, I hope I did.
For free?
Oh my god, you're giving finishers for free, RPR?
No, there's no way I finished Nia, right?
Hahaha.
How much would you charge?
Holy, why is the plane so loud?
Alright.
RPR, you're a jump master.
Yes.
Okay, listen.
One person lands on this building.
One on this building.
Then we loot towards this building.
Okay, I call this building.
You go there.
I go here.
Where am I going?
You have to open this one.
Hold up.
Left, middle, right.
Not this one.
I'm going here.
I'm going right side.
You're going right side?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cause I'm in middle.
I'm in middle.
Okay, okay.
Oh my god.
This team is over.
What do you mean?
We got first.
The moment we win the second game, nobody's gonna catch up to us.
There's no way.
We can't fuck around if we win two games in a row.
No, but like if we don't win, we make it intense on purpose.
But why?
So they think they have a chance and then you destroy them.
No, but if they think they don't have a chance, they'll give up.
And then it'll be even easier on Saturday.
Yeah, but like look.
Imagine how much more soul crushing is thinking you have a chance.
That's actually fucked up.
We made them move and we showed them that they never really had a chance to begin with.
Yeah.
I'm here to ruin dreams early.
I might be a sadist.
I might be an ass, not an ass.
Yeah, I'm gonna say that's pretty fucked up.
I might be swinging the other way.
Oh my boy.
So he is Minhera.
Oh my god, you are Minhera!
I told you I'm getting there.
Yeah, nice, nice.
Let's go.
Team slightly Minhera.
Team slightly Minhera, let's fucking go.
I'm gonna run double energy.
That's how serious I am.
Nah, it's time for new era RPR.
No more getting bullied.
Now I'm bullying.
Stand in line.
Who's next?
You can only bully people who are not in the voice chat.
That's sad.
You're on my team.
You want me to bully people.
This is for the benefit of us.
I have...
I have a turbo Havoc.
Oh, we're scanned by a beacon.
Oh, it was a long shot.
I need a scopa.
I would like these.
Yeah.
We need a backpack.
These backpacks are all ass.
I ain't carrying shit.
Yay!
I need massive.
Massive?
Oh, I got a...
I have a ball for you.
I have already...
Alright, listen to me.
We're going to move now.
We're going to where?
I'm ready.
Monument.
Fragment.
Monument, okay.
We ought redeploys.
Oh my god, gold PK.
Alright.
Yeah, I found one this time.
Hey guys.
I might run out of energy soon.
Last time we walked here, there was a team on our right trying to shoot us.
Yeah, but we'll shoot back.
We end their game quickly.
Yeah, yeah.
We're going to make them uninstall.
They won't even show up on Saturday.
Holy shit!
Yeah, I'm in my psycho era.
It's over.
It's over for everyone.
Three times.
I'm in my psycho era.
Oh my god.
He's 14 severe manhara and all it took was one game.
One game.
We keep winning.
It's going to keep going up.
The more we win, the crazier we get.
Our power levels increase.
Let's go.
Alright.
Oh, we go up.
Oh, he's following you.
Yeah, I was going to bet.
Why he's scared?
He's scanning us.
Now he has to die.
Kill him.
Stab him.
Why are you looking at us?
Do you want to go?
Yeah, we should kill him.
Now this guy is going to die next.
Who are we killing first?
Right or left?
I can't figure it out right now.
I'm thinking.
Oh my god, guys.
He's actually thinking.
I don't know, but someone's going to die.
I know that much.
Someone's dying.
Who?
Where should we go?
We're going straight in the middle.
Okay.
It's probably not a fragment zone.
What zone would it be?
It's probably this zone up here.
Then we should head over there, right?
I want to go scan there.
Yeah, but let's scan to see how many people are around us.
Okay.
I'm right behind you.
Maybe the north.
Yay!
We should have hit the old charger on the right.
We just walked by it like a bunch of dumbasses.
We really just did all that.
We don't need it.
Yeah, we don't need that.
You're right.
We're so much better.
I can call a package soon.
Or I can call it now.
Put it on the roof.
While Deto is scanning.
There's a PK here.
Put it on the roof next to you.
That's your cover.
That's not what I'm giving.
I see dead people.
Only one team here.
Yeah, only one team.
Oh no, they died.
Let's go.
Wait, I think this one might be there.
Because everyone is going there.
Okay, yeah.
Wait, you're right.
This guy's died.
Let's go.
I'm right here behind you, RPR.
What if they shoot back?
They have Crypto.
There's no way these guys can shoot back.
That's fucked up.
Yeah, but it's true.
I see them.
They're...
They have blue armor just like us.
Okay, end.
Yeah, blue armor.
They're on blue armor.
What are we scared?
We just won a game.
What are we scared of?
Blue armor.
That guy was hit 109.
The Caustic.
I got detected by the drone.
I put him on life support.
Knock, knock, knock.
What are we scared of?
They're not.
Come climb with me on the side here.
Me too, I'm climbing.
I fucked up the climb.
I forgot how to climb this.
They threw a Caustic all on me.
I'm gonna port you guys.
Come here.
Okay, I'm waiting.
It's on my side.
Guys, why did they throw a Caustic?
They threw a Caustic on me.
I can't do anything.
Ditto, you go to the port.
I'm gonna climb.
Okay.
Guys, I got it.
You tried to climb there 14 times.
I got out.
Ditto, we need you to shoot.
Yeah, break holders.
How dare they?
Yeah, I see one guy.
Don't get fooled.
They might be cheating.
They might have anti-wall hack.
Okay, we're gonna sandwich them.
Wait, it's just one guy.
Where's his teammate?
No, his teammate is in the corner.
He is?
Where the fuck is his teammate?
There's just two guys.
They never rest?
Yeah, no, we thirsted him.
That's a valuable comb that would have been good to me.
Don't kill me.
Oh, John.
Oh my god, Lifeline player.
Do you guys know?
TSM, TSM.
We gotta move.
There's places we have to be at.
Who scanned us?
I don't know.
You're here.
Here, here, here.
Behind us.
Are they... Nah, we gotta go up the hill.
We can't be put in this...
I have redeploy.
No, no, no, we're walking.
They're flying.
Yeah, because like... by the time the redeploy hits...
They're gonna take the spot.
I know my timings.
I watch Zero.
Yeah, but Zero predicts his zones correctly.
You didn't predict your zone correctly.
We won last game, didn't we?
I have...
And this...
Look what I pinged and it's in zone.
It's in third zone.
We're still chilling.
I have package, guys.
Oh, hey, bats.
I have like six bats.
I'm good.
I have eight bats.
Oh, I should take that then.
Listen, listen, listen.
I know where this is gonna end and I think we're in an opportune moment to win this game.
I've gained.
Where do we go?
We stay here.
We stay here?
Yeah, we play from this side.
Everyone's gonna... Listen, everyone right now is thinking, oh my god, I have to get in Cermy camp or I'm never gonna get in the circle.
But no one is thinking about like there's only 11 squads alive.
There's no one gonna be on our side of the circle.
We're just gonna be being chilling all game.
Yay!
I'm trying to figure out how to climb again.
Guys, I can't remember.
I can climb!
Guys, I'm gonna practice parkour, guys.
Why are you shooting at us, asshole?
Yeah!
On top.
TSM on top.
Yeah, yeah.
Guys, I figured it out.
There's nobody here on this side.
Oh, so far.
Oh, no!
I dropped!
I'm gonna be a mountain goat while you guys farm.
Oh, I'm gonna be a mountain goat while you guys farm.
Oh, my God!
I was turning my AC on, asshole!
Now you gotta die!
Where are you getting shot at?
Wait, there's people there.
Oh, shit!
Guys!
Oh!
I was stuck!
I was stuck, guys!
Yeah, I'm going to rez you now.
Are they pushing?
Ditto, cover!
Are they coming?
They're coming!
Oh, shit.
On the right!
You're fine, right?
I'm gonna bat in front of you guys.
I'm going to die!
I'm gonna die!
Guys, I won't blame...
This is not my fault.
I was climbing...
I was climbing, guys.
I will not have you blame me for this one I will not have you blame me for this one when you literally gave them a kill.
Like, you presented a free opportunity for this thing.
There is no way I will take blame for this.
I was climbing a mountain!
I had no AC on!
All in my bones!
You just sat on some fucking rock...
... getting beamed by 3 dudes and you died.
I mean, like, they had purple armor!
What was our purple armor?
Okay, and?
That's fine, that's fine!
Because they have 25 health more, does that mean you just died?
Yeah!
I couldn't have killed that guy that shot me...
... if I had full HP.
If I had purple.
I would 100% kill him.
Right, Ditto?
Yeah.
You know what I'm capable of, Doc?
You know what I'm capable of that you didn't think of?
What are you doing?
I am now going to assess the situation by myself.
I don't have rewind on.
Fuck.
I'm going to water you anyway, tomorrow.
What the fuck is that sound?
What?
What was that?
It's from you, Arpio.
Yeah, what was that?
We're in an office?
It's like a silent sound.
Did you hear the fucking office sound from him?
Yeah.
Wait, did you guys hear something?
Yeah, we heard like a fucking microwave or something.
Oh, yes.
Yeah.
I don't know a microwave.
What the fuck?
Where was the microwave from?
What?
Is something dying?
Am I dying?
We heard a microwave sound.
I was like, beep, beep.
Yeah, I heard it too.
Yeah, we heard it.
Something beeping?
Am I dying?
I can't believe it.
I blame like...
I think like RPR is actually going... getting Mejera right now.
I didn't make no sound.
There was like microwave in like a truck or something.
He's actually Mejera.
Oh my God, guys.
He's actually...
No, but you're like gaslighting me right now.
Like there's no way.
No, but we heard it, Ditto.
Ditto, you heard it too, right?
Yeah.
You're on Twitch right now, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Clip, clip, clip.
Oh, archive.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get the clip.
Clip, guys.
Ditto's chat.
Get that sound.
That was so...
Give me clip.
Max, you're confused.
No, we heard it.
Ditto and I heard it.
Yeah, we heard it.
Yeah.
No, no, I get that you heard some shit, but like I'm confused.
Like what would make a beep sound?
Like a beep sound in my room.
Like ghost.
Unless it's a bomb bomb.
A fucking ghost.
Your PC got...
Your PC got haunted.
A fucking ghost.
Maybe it's a bomb bomb.
A bomb bomb.
Oh my God.
He is gradually mined.
This guy is a controller.
Can we get him banned?
Which one?
There's so many.
Bloodhound.
No.
This should have been a PC MNK tournament only.
I request...
This is bullshit.
Yeah.
Fuck you guys for playing controller.
That's the easy way out.
Oh my God.
Wait, people are playing controller.
We're copying our comp now.
They are.
Of course they are.
They're copying our comp.
We're trendsetters.
We're like innovates.
Yeah.
We created this comp.
ALGS copied us.
Look at this guy cheating.
He missed Andy.
Dead.
Wait, did you have the clip?
Yo, I don't have the clip.
Someone claiming.
Somebody clip, clip, clip, clip.
We need to...
We need to find it.
Mike, listen.
Do you have a microphone in your room?
If you have...
Do you have it?
No, I don't have even...
I don't even have a microphone in my house.
Are there like trucks outside?
It's 2 AM.
What the fuck is this truck gonna be at 2 AM?
Trucks can drive at 2 in the morning.
What was that song then?
I live in bug fuck nowhere.
Oh, trucks can still exist.
Not...
I have a big garden.
There's a...
There's a road.
It's a long while until the road.
Maybe there's like a truck nearby.
Like...
Where?
In my garden?
Yeah.
Maybe it's like a baby truck.
No.
That's...
Yeah.
That's correct.
That's the correct one.
You got it there.
Yeah.
I knew I was right.
You got me.
Oh my god.
That makes sense.
Hot trucks in your area.
Okay, we're too far.
Ditto, get the clip, Ditto!
He thinks we're crazy!
I should say...
No, I'm not giving the clip.
Why are you getting the clip?
Check!
Okay, someone cut it for me!
Someone cut it for me.
Someone clip it, guys!
We need to prove that we're not crazy and RPR is crazy.
Did you get the clip?
Here, here, here.
Oh, oh!
Here's the clip.
I was saying...
Open chat here.
Are we putting it in the open chat so everybody can see the...
Wait, where did you post it?
Okay, here.
Hello, I'm back.
That guy was assassinated.
Okay, here.
We got the clip for you, RPR.
My internet got assassinated by someone.
This is not fair.
I got code-net.
You got code-net?
No, my whole internet died.
Your whole internet...
Someone is targeting me.
Wait, I'm gonna watch this clip.
I'm watching this clip too.
Okay.
There's a sound.
Yeah, this is the sound I heard!
What's that?
Yeah, what the fuck is that?
This is...
There's a ghost.
A dog... dog sound.
What is that?
Yeah!
Old RPR is scared.
He...
Now he's scared.
Yeah!
It's from you!
Yeah, it was from...
Because you didn't hear it, but we heard it.
Wait, what the fuck is that?
It was from you!
Guys, it's...
Yeah.
It's a bit scary that even he's confused.
Like...
No, but like...
It's a little worried.
Nothing...
Nothing here is capable of making that sound except for my...
AC or my PC.
Oh, it could...
That could be an AC sound.
I mean, maybe my AC went crazy for a little bit and go like...
Beep!
But like, why would you...
Why would you do that?
Did you not hear it?
Is your headphones like...
No, I...
I have in-ears, so I don't hear shit outside.
Oh!
I can't hear anything in my room.
You could stab me in the back and now...
It could be the AC, actually.
Your AC went fucking crazy there.
Why... Why did it do that?
It could be a ghost.
Why did the AC go...
Beep!
What...
What's it yapping for?
Well, you can't explain what ghost wants to do.
Why is it yapping like that?
Because the ghost hates you.
I don't fucking know.
What did you do?
I don't...
I'm not afraid of ghosts.
I'm afraid of faulty equipment.
You might need to get your AC checked.
How did that happen?
I just bought this new one.
Oh, it's a lemon.
Can they end the game faster so we can like go back to the game?
I don't know why.
At least I didn't have to go back to destroying this lobby.
Look, if like, our PR didn't throw, we'd be first place.
Right, Ditto?
Yes.
You literally fell over like a...
He didn't cover you.
Yeah, you didn't cover me.
I...
Oh, yeah, sorry, I didn't cover.
I only cracked one person that was shooting at you.
I'm sorry I couldn't crack all three at the same time while you're standing like the fucking statue of Jesus Christ on top of a mountain.
Like, hello?
Well, I'm glad that you agreed with me.
Like, I'm just trying to.
I apologize.
It's not my fault!
Well, it's not mine or Ditto's fault.
It could be Ditto's fault though.
Ditto, why didn't you cover RPR and I?
No, he is a pro.
He can cover himself.
That's so true!
Wait, that's so true though.
I'm going to go pee now.
I need my 5 minutes.
I need my time off this team for a couple minutes.
Consider this a smoke break.
We're not the problem here, right Ditto?
We're not the problem.
Yeah, we did everything correctly.
Yes, yes.
Yes!
Yeah!
Oh, that's so sad.
RPR always blaming teammates.
I know!
He always blames... That's why he retired.
You're so right.
He would be so mad.
That's why we say it when he's in the bathroom.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I thought he can't hear us.
No, he can't.
He doesn't have enough money for wireless...
...wireless headphones.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
We're... guys, it's okay.
We're...
We're going to win this next one.
Yes, yes, sure.
We win.
Yeah, I know.
He was trolling.
He was trolling us.
Like, he said this spot was like the best spot.
And then we died.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's so messed up.
He truly is a Minhera.
Okay, I win when we get the base spot.
Yeah, I know.
Right?
If it's the best spot, we wouldn't have died.
That is so true.
Yeah.
It would...
The best spot means that we should live.
Like...
Yes.
Oh, she's coming back.
Welcome back, RPR.
Oh, he's not back yet.
RPR.
RPR, welcome back.
We missed you.
Toilet one was taken, so I had to pee in toilet two.
Nice.
Hey, we missed you, RPR.
We were like talking about how good you were as IGL.
Stop fucking lying to my face.
Yes.
Are you trying to say Ditto would lie?
She said yes.
Yes.
Doggy, the last time I told him that my favorite Apex player was up here and he didn't believe me.
I don't believe you.
Wow!
That's fucked up.
You're my hero.
You're only second to zero.
There's about 15 players that are before me.
Yeah, but like we know you, so you're ahead of those 15 players.
Yeah, but you're also nocturnal, fun, like five more ahead of me.
Hal, Verhoest...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, keep adding.
Reps, Jen Burton...
This is really helping your case.
Mandy...
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Second to zero.
You don't even know zero.
Not yet.
Okay.
But he's already ahead of me.
Great top.
It's okay, this time.
This time we'll win first, right?
Right, Kiel?
Yeah.
Yeah, no, if my teammate doesn't turn into a statue and die randomly...
Alright, I'll pay attention.
I'll pay attention this time.
Yeah, that'll be good.
That'll be the plus.
It's okay.
We got this.
I believe in us.
I believe in believing.
Yay!
We win this.
Yeah, we win this.
Zed is gonna get 20k bomb for us.
Yes, yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If she doesn't get 4k, we kick her.
Okay.
If we lose, it's RPR's fault.
Yeah, if we lose, it's RPR's fault.
Why?
Okay, but like why?
Okay, I'm like trying...
Because you ideal.
In TSM, when TSM lost, it was Hal's fault.
So you got it.
So it's... since we're new TSM, it's your fault.
Because you ideal.
First of all, it wasn't Hal's fault.
It was always Evan or Jordan.
Okay?
It was never me.
But the chat says it's Hal's fault.
Yeah, but chat's always gonna blame the English.
They're like the most popular player on the team is always at fault.
Wait, but it's not my fault.
It's absolutely your fault every single time.
Without fail.
Oh, maybe there's someone near us.
Oh no.
Ditto, fly away.
Why?
It's RPR that's near you.
I want to be with you until...
Until death.
Yeah.
Like this team is just made to ruin my mental health.
This is insane.
Yeah, that's why we...
Team slightly Manera.
No, no, no.
We are team totally Manera right now.
Team severe Manera.
Team I'm just like over the edge.
It only takes one bad day.
It takes one day.
It doesn't even need to be bad.
Just one day.
There's a massive here.
Okay.
Oh, I got it.
All right, nice.
Team supreme Manera.
I'm going to need a hiatus number two, I think.
Maybe number three.
Maybe we'll combine a couple.
Wait, wait, wait.
Ooh.
Yeah.
I'm going to knock.
Nice.
I have a destructor here if anyone wants it.
Okay.
It's all right.
It's okay.
I'm using nemesis and massive.
All right.
I am hemlock nemesis, but I'd rather have hemlock Havoc.
Because I heard Havoc is like the gun now.
It's the only gun in the game you ever need.
If you have Havoc, you don't need anything else.
What's this?
Hammer point.
I'll need that.
I'm heading over for the knockdown shield.
Oh my God.
I want Havoc.
Yay.
Havoc?
Okay.
Actually, I'll find a Havoc for us.
That's not my job.
That is your job.
I tell you where to go and not what to look.
Wait, there's a Havoc here where Ditto is and she didn't ping it.
Oh.
Oh, I didn't see.
I didn't see.
Wow.
Ditto what?
I didn't see.
I'm your fault.
He didn't tell me.
How am I supposed to tell you what you're seeing?
You're so right.
You need it?
I can have it too.
You're so right.
How am I supposed to tell you what you're looking with your own eyes?
Well, just tell me what you want.
You have to say it.
Yeah.
You weren't assertive enough.
There's no way I could know what you want.
Look, English is her third language RPR.
You have to be more...
It's my 14th language.
Don't you hear him?
Ooh, nice.
Thank you.
I'm getting hungry.
I need a backpack that's not white.
There's a... ooh, I'll take that actually.
I need a Havoc.
I need energy...
Is there a purple helmet here?
Okay.
Yay.
I need energy magazine.
What are these stupid zones?
I don't know, IGL.
What are they?
It's all monument.
It doesn't tell me shit.
This map doesn't tell me shit.
Okay, I will scan.
I will scan.
I can't read.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Our better player is going to scan for us.
Okay.
There's someone there.
I'm with you, Ditto.
If you need help.
Our IGL is not with us.
Yeah, because you're supposed to follow me, not the other way around.
Yeah, but we were scanning.
We have to scan.
Yeah, we have to scan.
If you were a pro player now, you would know.
Why?
Why don't you wait for us?
Yeah.
Did I say we need a scan?
Yes.
When did I say that?
First game.
Yeah.
This is a game-by-game basis thing.
Okay.
You should have told us that after first game comes, it's different.
Where do we go, RPR?
She's unbelievable.
Just follow me.
Me.
Follow me.
Behind me.
Okay.
Yay.
I will only follow you.
Yeah, we're following you.
Yeah.
I'm not going to go anywhere.
Yeah, yeah.
We'll only follow you.
Good.
You won't be able to see us.
We'll only think for ourselves.
Yeah.
This is the shit I got to play.
I think they are alone.
I'm going to...
I'm not...
Yeah, I won't shoot.
If he doesn't tell us to shoot, we won't shoot.
Yes.
Do you guys want to lose?
Like, honestly.
Like, do you guys just want to lose?
But you told us to follow you.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
We're rotating of course.
What if somebody shows up while we're rotating.
While we are rotating, do we shoot?
It will be a case by case command that I'm gonna give you.
Oh, okay.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, I get it.
I get it.
For now, I will follow you.
Yeah, we follow you.
T-S-N-T-U Oh, they are scanning.
I need a fucking Havoc.
I have one.
You wanna look at it?
You can't win without Havoc.
Wasn't there a team here?
This thing is broken.
Yeah, there was a team here.
Yeah, but they are gone.
Because they are going zone.
Wait, we gotta scan again.
I have package.
Yeah, let's scan again.
IGL, should we scan again, IGL?
Yeah, guys.
IGL, should we do it?
Just rip it.
Let's do four more scans.
Wait, wait, wait.
Dude, the respawn beacon.
Are they gonna res?
Nope, that's three people.
What the fuck are you doing?
Kill them anyway.
Where are we going?
Almost cracked 500.
What the fuck?
Cracked two?
You didn't crack anyone, liar.
She's just lying now.
There's a purple helmet.
What the fuck?
I have so many batteries.
Is this Skyhook again?
There's three people.
There's three teams at Skyhook.
I'll tell you in a second.
Yes.
I have a redeploy.
Anyone use it?
We all have redeploys.
Yeah, but I really want the fucking Havoc.
What is this bullshit game?
We'll find a Havoc at Skyhook.
I'll put a redeploy here.
Why are you having like now?
Yeah, yeah.
I have redeploy.
Yeah, let's go with redeploy.
No one know who to shoot.
Yeah, this is a professional strat.
Where did they shoot me?
I wanted to redeploy first.
No, but pros always use multiple redeploys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
See, we're just doing what the pros do.
Exactly.
Adita, where are you walking?
I'm flying a skull.
We're trying to find you a Havoc.
Right, Adita?
We're rotating now.
Let's rotate.
Adita, you can fly...
What the heck?
Behind me!
Fight these motherfuckers.
Murder them in cold blood.
Where?
They shot me.
I see them.
To your right.
I'm the one on the right.
I'm next to you.
Two dead.
I'm here.
I'm with you.
Last person is running.
Oh, he is?
Yes.
Hey guys, I have zero damage.
Can I thirst the other guy?
These guys don't have a fucking Havoc.
This guy has a Havoc.
The guy that was running has a Havoc.
Yeah, but I'm not gonna chase.
I'll actually fuck him.
Let's kill him.
Wait, I wanna loot this though.
No, but he's already so far gone.
Yeah, he's so far.
We should go to his own.
They're playing Catalyst, Bloodhound, and the last person was what?
Bangalore?
They can't craft banners.
Let's camp them.
We can.
He's gonna bring me the Havoc.
I promise you.
Well, wait.
This guy has a Carbine.
I want a Carbine.
I wanna use the Carbine.
Hey, I'm dropping a Havoc.
Come here.
Sit right here.
Sit on me.
Alright.
I want this guy to deliver me a Havoc.
I didn't know if he actually does have a Havoc.
I was just...
I did clean the tube.
Over here.
Who the fuck is that?
That's a new team.
Why do they have purple?
Are they cheating?
Yeah, why do they have purple?
Where's our purple?
Fuck, you guys cheating, bro.
Yeah.
Cheating in a scrim?
What's wrong with you?
I'm taking shots.
I keep reinstalling his brain cells.
Let's go to the skyhook.
Okay.
I'm like 900 away from the purple guys.
I'm 151.
You're really putting in the hard work, aren't you?
I am.
I'm gonna scan.
Alright, just watch the vents.
Alright.
That's scary.
Wait, they scanned us from here.
Oh yeah.
I need like... more shield cells.
Hey, you found a Havoc.
Nope, that was a vault.
One team there.
Wait, are we going back to the same house?
Same house.
Same house and we win.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We play exactly the same.
And then we kill everyone and they die.
And we win.
Yay!
We're so good at this video game.
Wait, is there anyone in...
Why are they in the building that I want?
There's a battery here.
Why are you shooting at me?
Okay, I...
What the fuck is wrong with people?
They just wanna give you a hug.
Come here, let's go to this building now.
What the fuck is...
What is this contraption here?
Can you scan this building if there's anyone in there?
You're already in it, so like what's the point?
No, no, the other one to the right.
There is three dudes.
Well, they think they can beat us by taking the spot before us.
That's not how it works.
They have the new castle though.
What do we do?
Can somebody take my package?
Wait for my...
Wait, I'm gonna see what is in the package.
Where is the package?
More bats.
There's a lot of bats, guys.
I'll take it.
There's more bats here.
There's so many bats, holy shit.
I'm not saying no to bats.
I'll take a bat.
I got scanned.
I don't know from where.
I have seven bats now.
I'm gonna scan.
Oh, here.
Let's go back to our building.
This building is nicer and taller.
Okay.
On this one more.
Someone's close to me.
There.
They're behind us.
Behind the building.
Scan behind.
I'm here.
Wait, I hear them.
They're close.
Close.
Wait, wait.
One second.
I hear a lot.
Okay, no one here.
Are they not in there anymore?
Yeah.
Where are they?
Where did they go?
They were here.
Yeah, they disappeared.
I don't know.
I was probing to...
10 seconds.
Cool armor.
You know, I have so many bats.
I might as well use it.
Can't hear over there.
There's like a crypto.
Are they in there?
Okay.
They're still there?
Oh, okay.
They went in the diner.
Guys, stop.
They're breaking our doors.
Now I just wanna kill them.
Stop, guys.
You guys are pissing me off.
You're pissing me off.
Give me your feet.
Get out of here.
What do you think you're doing?
They're not beating us.
Can you stop shooting from all the way up there, dumbass?
No.
Why they have to shoot from far?
They are so far, but they still shoot us.
Let's go next building over.
Okay.
Where's the next building?
This one right in front.
I think there's a team here.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna scan.
Yeah, we fight these guys.
That guy's low.
Oh my god.
Guys!
Donkey, where were you?
Behind you.
Where was I?
Where did you shot from a different team?
Where did you shot my team on the other side?
No, no, no.
That was a bad call.
How was that a bad call?
There was literally a team shooting us to our right.
How is this a bad call?
Let's take this building.
There's a team here.
Me and Dito are there, but Doki is nowhere to be found.
I was getting shot by a team to our right.
How did you make that happen?
Because you guys were also getting shot by the same team.
I was literally watching it happen.
I didn't get hit.
That is not true.
Look at the death recap.
We have to scan first.
No, no, no.
I got shot by two different...
I got shot by three different people.
I'm not going to be blamed for this.
Look at your death recap.
You're not looking at your death recap because you know.
Once again, this is your fault, Doki.
How is it my fault?
I got shot by a Newcastle.
This team doesn't have a fucking Newcastle.
Okay.
Did you get shot by a Newcastle like I did?
Look at your death recap.
No, I have not.
No, you have not.
It's Catalyst and Bangalore that hit me.
You don't have a Catalyst.
Yeah, but I healed the damage that Catalyst did to me.
They don't even have a Catalyst.
Yeah, but Catalyst cracked me.
I popped a bat and then we pushed.
What do you mean?
You were so low.
Then I also got shot by the other team.
So why were you guys getting hit and I'm not getting hit?
It doesn't make any sense.
You guys have to dodge.
Catalyst!
Where is your portal?
Yeah, where is your portal?
Why would we report for five feet?
What?
We wouldn't get shot.
But you guys suck at dodging.
I can't help you.
You were also the one that got shot too.
What about you?
Before we pushed, yeah, okay.
I got shot.
Wow.
You literally dodged that shit.
You literally said you got shot.
By Bangalore, yeah.
I can't believe it.
RPR is through so hard.
No, but like where were you?
I was literally right behind you guys.
Getting shot by the other team.
But the whole team is here except for Doki.
Doki is not part of the team.
No, I was with you guys.
I was literally with you guys.
I was with you guys.
I was about to rez you because you died outside the door.
I was about to rez you because you died inside.
Of course I'm gonna crawl inside.
Why did you crawl inside?
I could literally have rez'd you.
There's no doors to begin with.
They broke the doors.
I could have rez'd you.
I could have rez'd you outside of the house.
And you're telling me that if you rez'd me outside the house, I could have rez'd you outside the house and then I could have killed by Bangalore?
You could have got free rez because nobody was pushing you outside the house?
You could have done so much but instead you're sitting here dead and yapping like...
You died first.
I died for the team.
I died for the team too.
You died last so you didn't die for the team.
I...
No!
It's right that it's not good that Lifeline died first.
Yeah, that's so true Ditto.
She's Lifeline.
Why are you on her side?
She just left us in a 2v3.
That is not true.
It was like a 1v2 from what I saw.
No, it was a 2v3.
It was a fucking 1v2.
I saw it.
There was like one guy in there.
Oh my god.
Now she's just gaslighting.
You know what?
Maybe RPR should play Lifeline.
Yeah, you should IGEL and then...
Okay, no, no, no.
IGEL can be on Lifeline.
Where are you pulling this...
Where are you pulling this factor?
Where are you pulling your stats from?
From years of experience!
You haven't been a competitive player for so long.
Meta changed.
Listen to me.
How the fuck is Lifeline going to IGEL when he has to be behind his whole team?
It's the same thing.
How is he going to IGEL when he literally has to be behind everyone?
What is he going to tell them?
Yeah, you guys go there.
You fuck them up, boys.
Yeah, I got your back.
I mean, you gotta try it out and see how much better it is.
I'm not going to...
I'm not going to do this stupid shit.
Okay?
We're going to play proper Apex Legends.
Dude, how come we died?
I would explain your mistakes to you.
Like...
Are you like an M?
You want to hear them over and over again?
Like you just want me to keep shitting on you?
I mean...
You're the reason why we died though.
You were not with the team!
Why are you five seconds late to the move?
I'm sorry.
I was five seconds late.
I was like one second.
Stop the gap!
That fight was like at least ten seconds long.
We're not winning, guys.
Oy vey, oy vey.
We're not winning.
Yeah, we're not...
I'm going to fucking murder you.
Like the second game, you're standing still like a statue.
You get beamed from across the planet.
We get pushed.
And now you're not with the team and you're gaslighting.
And then you're crying.
We're now winning.
Like what more can I do?
What more can I do?
Ditto, what more can RPR do?
Ditto.
Ditto, what more can he do?
Doki is literally...
Second game, you're literally that statue on top of Rio de Janeiro.
Jesus.
That's on the...
above the clouds.
Calm down, calm down.
Their IGL is on Bloodhound.
Okay.
Fuck what they do.
They're obviously worse than us.
But they killed us.
They didn't kill us.
We died to you.
This guy is ranked 26th spread.
When have you been top?
Ranked 26th spread.
Wow.
You won a fucking championship.
Like you're gonna compare me to a ranked 26th spread.
But what was your...
Motherfucker's playing...
He's playing in kindergarten while I was playing in the NBA.
Like what are we talking about?
But what was your peak rank?
It was top 10.
No number for that?
No.
I don't remember.
It was me knocking Raptor.
We grinded one season to top 10 and then we stopped.
But did you end on top 10?
I have better shit to do like winning tournaments instead of playing ranked.
What is wrong with you?
Wait this guy...
The team that killed us won.
They're called THC.
They're high as fuck and they won against us.
These motherfuckers are high out of their minds.
They probably popped a fucking edible.
The edible motherfucker said...
But we died to this team.
We died to this team.
Okay we go next.
The next map.
Oh wait that's the good map.
We go next and...
In the next game...
If...
Who die first that is their fault.
Yeah yeah yeah.
I agree.
This is so stupid.
Why are you guys so focused on who's dying first?
And who's fault it is.
Instead of winning the fucking game.
What are you guys focusing on?
But that's...
That's how we know.
Up here you started.
You started.
You always blame.
Yeah you're always blaming people.
You guys don't understand that when you...
Yeah that's so true.
When you're the IGL you get blaming privileges.
If you want to blame other people...
Go ahead and IGL.
I think you gotta...
I think...
Calm down.
Yeah calm down.
This is just a scrim.
Don't take it so seriously.
The best thing to tell them is to calm down.
That's really smart from you guys.
We're really gonna help out here.
It's okay.
Just slow down.
It's just a scrim.
You don't have to take this so seriously.
You literally five minutes before you were crying.
Why are we not winning?
What do we want about it?
We're just here to have a good time.
Right Ditto?
Yeah.
So it doesn't matter if we don't win?
I mean...
Yeah.
Now it matters.
Really?
The ALGS champion winner not winning a simple scrim against VTubers?
I don't care.
Personally I would go fuck.
That doesn't look good for you though.
I mean I don't care.
I'm gonna get my win one way or another.
Through this tournament.
Are we doing the same comp?
Of course we are.
What the fuck are we gonna switch up?
I don't know.
It's a different map.
Different map?
Same shit.
It's a different packaging.
Who cares?
We're gonna talk about Bangalore.
Fuck is Bangalore gonna do for us?
Smoke us.
We're making portals for us.
We have portals.
I made 15 portals just in the first game.
Yeah but that's the first game.
What about the second and third?
There was zero portals then.
God how was that?
I couldn't port you when you died so fast.
It was over too quick.
What was I gonna port?
To the next lobby?
That's better than no port.
Okay.
We will do Vayne in Stormpoint.
Yeah we're gonna try so hard.
My game crashed.
Yeah we're trying so hard right now.
I'm coming back in.
I'm gonna try so crashes.
Don't worry.
Now after I get back in.
I'm gonna try so hard.
Where's the code?
We told them not to start yet.
I crashed.
I mean you could play...
Why do we wanna be meta slaves?
Because we're not winning.
We're not winning because of the comp.
It really ain't the comp's fault.
It could be the comp issue.
Wait what's the...
What comp would you play?
I don't know.
You're the IGL.
So if you wanna switch the comp but you don't have any fucking ideas what to do.
Then why do you switch?
I didn't say I wanna swap.
I'm just giving a suggestion.
Suggestions from here on out are banned.
Wait we're 4th place guys.
We're not even 2nd.
Okay.
From here on out suggestions are banned.
Wait that's fucked up.
I make the rules.
I IGL.
If you wanna make the rules you can IGL.
Okay but that's like...
That's pretty fucked up.
Okay let's do it.
We listen.
We listen to up here.
Yeah we're good listeners.
If we listen to you and we don't win first.
Then I think that's just an IGL problem at that point.
Yeah.
I will listen to every comp you say.
I'm gonna listen to every comp you say.
And like I will make sure I wouldn't be super 100% focused.
So if you don't listen what happens?
What if you don't listen?
Well it's never gonna happen.
What if your ADHD kicks in?
I don't have ADHD.
You're a streamer.
I got tested.
I just diagnosed you.
Where's our land again?
I don't know.
Okay.
Well there's a barometer.
Yeah I heard it.
See if I had ADHD I wouldn't have heard it.
You heard it five minutes after I said it.
There's no...
This is the comp.
Trust me I've done this shit for years.
I always played Lifeline, Bloodhound and Raid.
Yeah but like you retired years ago.
So you think I'm just fucking...
A person retires and just gets dumb?
Like just forgets what they...
It's like riding a fucking bike.
You never forget this shit.
Same shit just different packaging.
The meta changes.
Yeah but the game is dog shit like it was two years ago.
It's still the same shit.
No.
Now we have EVO armor.
We had that shit two years ago too.
No we don't.
We did have EVO armor two years ago.
That was a year ago.
No we had EVO...
We had EVO armor for years.
We just didn't have this stupid shit that you can't charge anymore.
Yeah but we didn't have skills too.
So as I said we have EVO charger.
But dog shit.
Skills wow what a big change.
It's so different.
Armors don't spawn in anymore.
Now you can have your Horizon Q 5% off.
Yeah.
It's faster than before.
Wow.
Yeah but you said it's the same game.
And I'm here to prove to you that it's not the same game.
It's the same dog shit that they just packaged in a different box.
And they're doing this shit every season.
Yeah but we have new legends too.
We have...
That everyone uses.
Don't forget everyone uses this Altair legend.
Everyone...
She's so useful that just people just...
Part of every comp.
It's just unbelievably useful.
There's a gold sentinel...
Not gold sentinel...
We also have Vantage.
That one is also very useful.
Wow Conduit.
One team in 15 teams uses Conduit.
But Conduit was meta at one point.
Yeah for like 5 minutes.
And then they fucking murdered her.
What about...
Catalyst.
Catalyst was like...
Catalyst was out when I was competing.
Doesn't count.
We don't count that one.
We don't count it but he's new.
She's new.
She's not new if she came out 2 years ago.
Hey here's a Havoc.
Okay you're on the hallway.
Yeah there's a Havoc.
Oh now you don't want our Havocs?
Oh yeah let me quadruple wield fucking Havocs.
Cause I got 4 hands.
You can dual wield it.
Nothing's stopping you from that.
I want shotgun.
Like do you wanna lose?
No we're listeners right?
We're listening.
Yeah we're listening to you.
You guys are doing a great job at listening.
Thank you I'm glad you think so.
This is some real high quality listening.
Yay!
He's complimenting us.
We said we will listen to you but we didn't promise you that we are gonna do what you say.
Oh okay.
So you just wanna lose.
So she's just planning to lose.
I didn't say that.
Yeah we will do what you say.
We will do what you say.
I'm making the battery.
Why don't you try?
I'm trying.
I'm making the battery.
I need a therapist.
No you don't.
You have us.
You guys are my therapist.
We will do it for free.
That's how good friends we are.
I'll pay you to stay away from me.
Am I on like 280?
Let me double check.
Guys I don't think I'm on the right frames.
How much frames do you need?
I think I'm on 60?
No I'm on 200.
Okay there we go.
Don't worry guys.
My eyes are just tired.
Don't worry my eyes are just tired.
I just said movement.
Alright here you go.
Move now?
Yeah I'm right behind you.
Ditto's not listening.
Okay what are we in kindergarten?
Like hello?
I listen.
She's not listening teacher.
Okay I'm like.
Have you taken this seriously for a second?
I'm going.
We're following you.
When we die you're going to be like.
Why are we not winning?
Why are we not winning guys?
Why aren't we?
What's your vote?
What's your own vote?
Mr. RPR can I get a hall pass?
No.
No passes anywhere.
No suggestions.
No talking back.
Nothing.
No.
We win a game.
That sounds like I don't know that doesn't sound right.
It's none of the rules like I said.
It's not like.
It's not like against a human, right?
I'm not a fucking teacher.
I have no license.
Okay.
Oh there's a team there, yeah.
We kill these fucking spiders and take their shit.
Okay.
Okay teacher.
Hey, there's another bat.
Oh, I want a bat.
Okay.
I have six bats you wanted.
I have four.
Yeah.
Wait, there's people over there.
Stay at the station.
Are we gonna get sandwiched?
Yeah, are we?
No, we are going to sandwich them.
This is all part of my plan.
We're following you.
This is all part of my master plan.
They're right here in front of me.
They're right in front of me.
Okay, end their life.
Look at this nade.
One, two, three, bomba.
There's a guy on top.
I'm gonna throw another bomba.
Wait, there's a guy on the...
Are we gonna fight?
Well, I mean...
We gotta kill the guy that's close if we wanna fight.
There's another bat here.
There's so many bats.
The guy that's close ran away.
Like, why is he running?
Because there was a team behind us.
There is?
What are you gonna do?
Why are you guys so scared?
I'm not saying...
No, I'm not saying you guys.
Them guys over there.
Why are they so scared?
There's a light mag there.
Purple light mag.
One HP!
162!
How is he alive?
He's got 175.
That's why he's alive.
I'm here.
They have conduit.
See, they're using conduit.
There's some stupid shit.
You guys are fucking cheating.
I'm okay.
If conduit is cheating, then why don't we use conduit?
It's conduit bad.
These guys wanna terrapod us.
And he has a longbow.
Now I'm pissed.
Why are you?
He's not gonna fight.
He wants to terrapod us.
This game is dog shit.
I'm waiting for you, RPR.
Let's go.
I have redeploy.
I waited for you to use yours.
Someone is also redeploying there.
We are now in a race of who's gonna die first.
Not us, that's for sure.
What if I get shot?
You're not gonna get shot because they can't shoot us.
Okay.
In the tunnel.
You're right.
You're so right, IGL.
We listen.
Yes.
In the tunnel, get to this house.
Keep moving to the next house.
And we don't stop moving.
If you stop moving, you're dead.
I'm gonna pick you up.
If you die, you're dead.
Wait, why didn't you keep your portal to save us?
There's no portals in this world.
That sounds like a guy that wasn't gonna...
No!
I need a bat.
I got shot.
Pop your bat, stay alive.
Okay.
I'm alive.
Get to this house now.
Can you climb this up?
Yeah, you can.
Yay!
We're alive!
CRPR, we listen.
I'm putting the best spot in the zone.
Really?
Yes.
Where do you think the zone is gonna go?
I don't know.
Your IGL.
If this shit pulls here, I mean, Jesus does not love us.
Wait, then you're wrong.
But I'm never wrong.
But you were wrong last time.
Okay.
I was not wrong.
Last game, we were in the right spot to win the game.
You died.
Because you were wrong.
How was I wrong?
We were in the correct spot!
You're right.
You're always right, RPR.
I am always right.
Because I'm the IGL.
You're so right.
So that means if you're always right, then we should win.
Even if the zone does not go to us, we have an easy walk up to the zone no matter what.
I'm not gonna go to the zone.
And we have double choices.
We can choose to go here or go here.
We have so many choices.
I watched the right side.
Or should I watch, RPR?
Good job, Ditto.
Just stay alive.
You just watch your life.
But I want to contribute.
You're contributing by being alive.
But I want to do more.
Okay, then stay at that house and stay alive.
Okay.
But where are you gonna watch?
Everywhere.
I'm literally looking everywhere.
I'm looking at the house.
Yep.
I have a package.
Good job.
Guys, I got a package.
Yay!
There's more bats and a purple helmet.
What a shit package.
You need a purple helmet.
They don't have purple helmets.
Ditto, you need this.
Oh yeah, I need it.
You need to heal.
You're not full health, Doki.
Go full health now.
Wait.
You told me to heal.
Yeah, I mean, why do I have to tell you to heal?
You shouldn't hold this.
Because I wasn't told.
I'm the listener.
Yeah, you told me to do whatever you say.
So if you get hit by 150, you're not gonna heal?
Until I kill you.
That's when you know I'm a...
I quit this team.
Find a new Imperial Hall.
No, you're not supposed to leave TSM.
I'm going to Dark Zero.
It's over.
We're all playing now.
But you're not even a controller player.
This game is shit.
You got the zone wrong.
You're definitely not going to Dark Zero.
We're gonna go for this.
We're gonna go for this house.
Okay.
We're gonna play from there.
And then the zone is probably gonna pull here.
And we're gonna go through this.
And blah blah blah.
Let's go Rez it.
Okay.
Everyone has purple armor now.
Yeah, everyone has purple.
But we're still blue.
Fuck them.
So what?
They can't aim and we can.
That's the only thing that matters.
We are TSM.
Yeah, but that was not an aim issue.
It wasn't?
No, it was a brain issue.
On your behalf.
Get this fucking house.
This is our fucking house.
We have a house.
I even washed all of our...
I want this as well.
I want everything.
We're taking everything.
We are TSM.
We can hold everything.
Look at these guys.
I wash all of my...
How dare you crypto.
You know who I am.
I'm Imperial High.
Imperial RPR.
Tell me if they pushing you.
They're not gonna push.
I think they're getting ult charge off... not ult charge.
Shield charge.
I wash up left side.
If you have a nade, break their door.
But they're just gonna wall it back.
Yeah, so what?
I'm gonna shoot them in the window.
The door is broken.
Why are you coming back with this stupid fucking drone?
Because they have the resources.
Well, there's a nade here.
You wanna use it.
You're better at aiming the nade than us.
Yes.
Apparently.
That's how it works.
Pro players have good aim on everything.
There's an indicator.
Oh, they broke the door.
Shoot them.
They did the door thing.
Yeah, we knew that was gonna happen.
Then what's the point of nading the door?
Because maybe in the second that I broke the door, I could see one of them and one clip them.
But you didn't.
I'm gonna go to the other side.
It's a fucking... it's a gamble.
I hate it here.
I'm gonna hold here.
You guys hold there.
Okay.
Wait, there was... here, here, here.
Here, there.
Kill those motherfuckers now.
We need help.
He's jumping up.
I know one.
Nice.
We go together.
Three, two, one.
Okay, zip take now.
Go.
Okay, okay.
I'm with RPR.
One HP Bang.
Bang is one.
I got a heal.
He wants to kill me so bad.
He's a hater.
I got a heal drone now for you.
Whoops.
That was interesting.
That guy wanted to take me down with him.
It was some hater shit.
He was straight hating.
What did you do?
Why is he hating on you?
I don't know.
Some toxic shit these VTubers.
I swear to God.
Yeah, so toxic.
Oh, I got purple guys.
What's the third person?
Why do we see two dead boxes?
Third person is on the ground, maybe?
Oh, Dita is...
Oh, there's an alt-xl.
Do we need it?
You guys stay here.
I'm gonna hold this.
You guys are gonna hold the house.
There's a hatch.
You guys are gonna move it to zone.
Someone's on my right.
I already have this spot.
What the fuck?
But they're in the zone there.
Okay, I'm heading over to you, RPR.
No, no, no, no.
Are you listening?
No, I forgot.
You guys hold the fucking house and you move it to zone.
Okay, I heard you this time.
Wait, they're behind this rock.
Yeah.
They're looking at us.
I'm on my way.
They're looking at me right here.
Why the fuck are they looking?
Who the fuck...
Dita, why are you here?
I don't know, but I'm by myself now here.
Now this is insanity.
No!
I'm making a port to dodge this stupid fucking Bangalore roll.
Bangalore's low.
They got Kipto Ood.
Bangalore, I almost cracked Bangalore.
It's okay.
They're pushing.
Bloodhound pushing.
On me.
I cracked the fuck out of him.
I got a bat.
I'm on the side of the wall, by the way.
They're gonna push us through.
Everyone come here.
Okay.
I'm coming back.
They're on me.
Oh my god.
I got beamed.
Got one.
Nice one.
I need help.
I need help, RPR.
Oh...
Ameen.
I was with you.
What did you expect from me?
I got beamed.
It was Verhulst again.
Verhulst.
Why were you not thinking?
They're Hulst.
You have no more damage, Verhulst.
It's the controller player again.
It's Evan!
All I'm saying is that I was with Imperial RPR.
Good job!
Nah, this probably got beaten by this controller Andy.
Hey, who's Raven then?
We don't have Raven.
We don't have the budget for that.
That's why we're losing!
We don't have Raven!
We don't have the budget for that shit!
Where's Slave?
Where's your Raven?
Maybe if we won this scrim we would have the budget for it.
Hel took all the budget!
That's why we have Imperial RPR.
He went to Dark Zero and took everything.
He took all the budget, guys!
Fucking asshole!
I can't believe it.
What is this fight?
What am I watching?
I don't fucking know.
Wait, they won that.
Wait, what?
They got traded.
Why couldn't we be the team that didn't have to fight everybody?
Because we got pushed and there's...
Sometimes in life you get pushed and you have to win the push.
And that's what the Apex is all about.
How come we didn't win the push?
We listened to you.
Oh wait, somebody didn't listen.
I don't think we need lifelike.
Listen, I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't know what you want me to do.
I knocked one and cracked two people in that fight.
I really can't do more than that.
I knocked the other.
I got my one.
You didn't knock anyone.
There was two guys alive.
I got my one.
I helped you.
Who did you knock?
Yourself?
I covered you.
To get you your one.
Okay, I knocked my one.
Now it turned into I covered you.
So you could get your one.
I think we...
We could win Bangalore.
Yeah, I agree.
And Watsons or another character.
Okay, Doki, you're not playing Bangalore.
What am I playing?
Bangalore.
I'm playing Bangalore?
Nice.
Honestly, I agree.
And yeah, sure.
That's going to be so much better.
I will play Watsons.
Why would you play Watsons?
We need Bloodhound.
We need Bangalore and Bloodhound.
So we can smoke them then wallhack them.
Yeah.
I agree with the Bloodhound pick.
No, how about another one?
The last character.
I'm playing Wraith.
Wraith.
Because Portal is important.
We have Bangalore smokes.
Yeah, okay.
So you're telling me Bangalore smoke is going to port us across the planet?
Yes.
Okay.
Guys, it seriously isn't a team comp thing.
We're not losing to team comp right now.
Okay, to be fair, Ditto didn't...
Derholz didn't listen to that last comp to be fair.
I would admit.
I listen.
Listen, listen.
Bangalore, Wraith.
This is fine.
It works.
Wait.
Bangalore, Wraith, Bloodhound.
Okay, Ditto, you're Bloodhound.
I'm going to play Bloodhound.
No, I'm going to play Bloodhound.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, you're Bloodhound.
I'm going to play Bang.
Wait, no.
I want to play Bloodhound.
I'm going to play Pathfinder.
No, you're playing Wraith.
You need to be on Wraith.
No, I'm way better on Pathfinder.
No, but what about the Portal?
We have Ziplines.
But the Portals were important.
Yeah, but Ziplines.
Okay, alright, Chelsea.
Okay, go Zipline.
I'll show you.
This map is made for Pathfinder.
Okay.
I'll show you.
This is scrims.
We have two more games to win a game.
We're trying things out.
It's scrims.
We're sixth place.
Who's fourth is the half, huh?
That's okay.
It's a scrim.
But you can win if we win.
We won two games.
No, we won one game.
We won one game, Ditto.
No, two more games.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Two more games for us to win.
You're right.
Yeah, this time and next time.
Yeah, and I'm going to play Pathfinder.
If we can't lose, I'll show you the sauce.
Okay, so what do we play then?
Angler and Bloodhound.
How did you forget already?
I don't get it.
I don't know.
You were saying Wraith and then suddenly you swapped to Pathfinder.
So I assume there's going to be more swaps.
I swapped my character, not yours.
Okay, I will play more.
Well, I can save, okay?
I will shoot everyone.
You guys are...
You're complaining when I play Wraith, then you don't want to play Path.
What do you want me to do?
I'm the fucking in-game leader.
I decide what I do.
You're saying different comps now, so I'm confused.
Because we're scrimming.
This is all about trying shit out.
Yeah, but then you said we didn't need to try new things out because it worked.
Yeah, but you guys are so hellbent on trying things out, so now we're really trying things out.
I was fine.
I was fine with doing whatever.
No, but like, Dito was clearly not satisfied with our team comps, so now we're trying things out.
Okay, well...
I'm trying, I'm trying.
So who are we blaming then?
No one.
Why do you want to blame people?
Why can't we just focus on winning?
Wait, what am I playing?
What am I playing?
Bangalore?
Yes, Bangalore.
Yes, yes, yes.
You wanted to play Bloodhound, didn't you?
I'm so confused.
Which one do you want to play?
Joki.
There's so many swaps, I'm getting confused.
We swapped the one game.
Nothing changed.
Oh my god, you're frying my brain so that I don't have any left.
I'm going to play Bloodhound.
Yes, you're frying my brain so that I don't have any left.
Bye.
I just got overwhelmed because we keep changing stuff.
Team Rocket is already dead!
Oh, they got contested.
Prepare for trouble!
Make it double!
Wait, they got contested.
Why are they dead?
Because they got contested.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can contest people if you want to.
Oh, I see.
Yeah.
Why there's no one contesting us?
Because they're scared of us.
I don't know why.
Why the fuck would they contest us when they know they're gonna lose?
But we lost.
But if we lost...
Oh, Jesus Maria.
Yeah, yeah, okay.
We lost.
I get it.
We get it.
We lost.
You like losing?
No, that's why I won.
So why do you keep repeating that we lost?
Because I was just fact-checking you.
Fact-checking?
This is really bad.
I'm gonna go for the team morale right now.
I am Lucy.
Calm down, Arp here.
Calm down.
It's just a game.
I will fight you.
Oh, hey, there's a Havoc.
Are they?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's two Havocs.
I like Havoc.
I want both.
Both are my speed.
I'm on Flatline 301.
I will shoot you.
Flatline 301.
I need both on my speed.
I want Prowler.
I want Prowler actually.
I like Prowler.
I need energy ammo.
There's a lot of energy on this area.
Good.
Hey, people are donating to me for your therapy funds.
Just send it over to my PayPal.
I'll use it properly.
It's called alcohol.
Guys, don't worry.
I'm here to raise funds for Arp's therapy.
It will go straight towards him if you donate your Super Chats to me.
There's no therapy in life.
You just drink it off.
And you forget.
Arp, you didn't ping.
Yeah.
Ping what?
Mastiff.
Yeah.
Why the fuck would you want Mastiff?
Play Mera.
Why?
I want to use Mastiff.
I'm going to go here with the beacon.
I'm going to grab a battery.
If you found a vault, tell me.
I know where there's a vault.
There's energy here.
I saw a vault earlier.
There's a key.
I'll use Mastiff.
I can't use a survey beacon because we're in White Arms.
I have a scan.
Yeah, scan.
And then we can get blue.
Pathfinder can't do shit until he gets blue armor.
Useless fuck.
You still need the Mastiff.
Oh my god, guys.
Oh wait, here.
There's a gold one here.
Does anyone want that?
Oh my god, that's great.
Up here.
Ping it.
You want that?
Do what?
What do I want?
Energy.
Energy magazine.
Yes.
I like that.
Great.
I'm here, guys.
Your best teammate.
I will drop a purple one.
Alright.
One team there.
There's a lot of teams doing the storm catcher.
Okay.
Maybe we can go gap that one.
Yeah, go grab.
We need armor, we're literally poor.
They're so poor.
We're so poor.
Yes.
We need a wellness check.
I'm okay.
Okay, I'm gonna go gap Giamma.
I need therapy.
I'm gonna help.
Okay.
I got blue.
Yeah!
What do you need the blue for?
I don't speak to stupid.
If you have anything smart to say, I'll answer.
And not these stupids that are gonna be answered.
But like, a stupid person can get smarter by educating them.
They say no questions are dumb.
You proved it wrong just now.
You're not teaching me anything, so I'll stay stupid forever.
Oh fuck it, you've been playing this game for five years.
But you've been playing it professionally for five years.
You know what the...
Ah, I refuse.
I refuse.
Where's the zone ending?
I'm moving along.
With or without you.
I'm right here.
What are you saying?
We're right behind you.
You didn't see me.
Yeah!
How could you ignore Ditto like that?
I'm moving with or without you.
How could you ignore her like that?
Yeah, what the fuck?
Fine.
Wait, why did you guys close the door?
From me.
Oh, me too.
I'm sorry.
She slammed the door in your face.
Do we need alt-accel?
Nah.
I don't think we need alt-accel.
No.
We wait here for 12 seconds.
Okay.
Where should we go next?
Well, he said we gotta wait here for 12 seconds.
Okay.
Wait, you have that airline?
You paid money?
I just said it five seconds ago.
I just said it.
No.
See?
That's just me.
I listened.
I literally listened.
Go back?
Okay.
I knew what was going on.
Great job, doggy.
Like, for once, you listened.
Only took six games.
Five.
There's someone on my left here.
These guys need to die.
Okay.
I got shot.
What the fuck?
I need a heal.
Wait, hold up.
I gotta go back.
I can see.
Come here.
I'm gonna ult them.
These motherfuckers are angry at us for no reason.
Now we gotta kill them.
They're gonna come inside now.
Are they?
I don't know.
I ulted.
How much do they have of death wish?
I'm worried about behind us, too.
Why are they here?
What the fuck could they possibly be doing here?
Why am I lagging?
Yeah, you're lagging.
Yeah, yeah.
I see them.
They're outside.
Wait.
No, they're not.
What the fuck are they, girl?
You hear that?
There was a vibration.
Let's go.
Why are you shooting at me, bro?
Where are they?
Here.
Hit a hundred.
Conduit.
They're coming over?
Right here.
Behind us.
She went inside the house.
These guys need to die.
Okay.
Why don't we die?
I think murder is about to happen.
Oh, I shot fucking Ditto.
I'm starting with this.
Never mind.
I can't do that.
They removed that.
Fuck.
What did they remove?
I can't go on the... on the...
They're re-deploying.
I'm not gonna let them do that.
30 on the Watson.
Conduit cracked.
Slow.
Ooh, careful.
I cracked... I cracked all of them.
All of them are cracked.
Oh, shit.
You're right.
No, that's just two Conduits.
Am I right?
Oh, my God.
It got stuck.
A Conduit flash on me.
115.
It's okay.
Roof.
That Bloodhound is sitting every Wingman shot in the world.
I need a... I need a heal.
I'm getting a better spot.
I'm coming back.
I want these guys dead.
That's a different team.
Chill here.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
You stay over here.
I'm gonna go back a little bit.
I'm gonna be here so I can...
Let this team knock them.
They just knocked them.
Look at that Evac.
Okay.
I'm looking.
There's no way that person...
They're even.
No way.
He's... That's... That's crazy.
Yeah.
That was crazy.
One person took the...
They're taking two.
That was... That's only two here.
People here.
We should fight them now.
Okay.
There's only two people on the right side.
I'm almost down.
Where's his teammate, though?
Oh?
Did we get... Did they get tripped by one guy?
Fucking... I don't know.
I don't know.
What the fuck is going on?
What is going on here?
I don't know.
I'm losing it.
Give me that.
I'm loosing.
Loot.
I am lagging so bad.
You are.
I hear it.
This is why we're losing too.
Am I... Is my voice lagging?
Yeah.
Your voice is lagging a little.
You're going robot.
Really?
She's making...
Where are we going, by the way?
I don't have bat anymore.
Oh, here.
I got you.
I got two.
Okay.
Thank you.
I think my internet is fucked.
Oh, no.
That's not good.
How are you gonna kill everybody for us?
There was a fucking storm today.
There's a... I'm gonna replay.
Yeah, I have a replay.
Go zone.
I'm looking behind us just in case.
Oh my god, I'm lagging.
I'm gonna sue someone.
Oh my god, this is on purpose.
They're doing this to sue me on purpose every time.
This is like East Coast servers.
So you even have like the benefits too.
Yeah, I don't know why I'm lagging.
I think it's like... I told you there's a massive storm today.
I'm not.
But I'm lagging in Discord too.
I told you there's a massive storm today.
It fucked something up.
Now I'm lagging.
Oh no.
That's not good.
The fucking electricity in the air is a machine.
I don't know how science works.
Let's go here.
Okay.
We're right behind you.
There's probably people in these houses, right?
We got reapplied.
You wanna play?
No.
I wanna walk.
Yeah, but I wanna walk and see what's in front of us before we evac into someone's face and die.
That wouldn't happen, right?
Nope.
That never happens to anyone.
Just like that one team that landed on us didn't die when they landed on us.
Yeah, but that was on purpose.
Yeah, they wanted to die.
No, they thought they could kill us.
They blocked this door off.
That's weird.
Why would you let us play too?
Dang it.
I'm gonna watch our back.
Oh, they're evacing on my left.
That's murder time.
I don't think they have a compact.
Oh, there's a team above them.
That's why.
Okay.
I'm gonna watch our back.
God, I hate lagging.
It makes my blood boil.
That guy's one.
Broke down.
I hit 10.
He was not one.
You're gonna fly?
You're lying.
Okay.
He was... Oh, okay.
He was 12.
Like, we won't be...
You're gonna fight?
We'll fight?
No, we're just poking.
We're just poking.
Poking, poking, poking.
Oh, they're fighting down here.
There's downs.
We go.
Okay.
I watch our back.
One team dead.
I'm heading over.
Nice one.
I don't think we can anymore.
Okay.
I'm heading back.
My armor's fucked.
Word champ.
I smoked our backs.
Ditto, where are you?
I'm watching our back.
Tell me if you wanna fight.
I will go there.
What the fuck?
What?
Okay.
I want to watch our back anymore.
Okay?
If we get third body, I...
So don't blame me.
You didn't even say to me that...
No, I totally wasn't talking the entire time.
I wasn't talking.
I was just imagining that part.
Wait, they have red armor.
Kill these guys.
Red armor cracked.
Okay, okay.
We're good.
Close to me.
I'm ulting.
Right below me.
This is Daryl.
Daryl.
I gotta pull back because they're so horny.
By the way.
I'm safe here.
Ditto.
Ditto's way up ahead.
Oh my gosh.
Left side.
Left side, I think.
On me?
Left side.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
In a small...
How could he see me?
He's like...
How could he see through smoke?
Wait, what?
How is he seeing through smoke?
Yeah.
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck?
I might be dead.
He might push me.
He's pushing.
He thought you were gonna push.
Yeah.
That's some bullshit.
Like, what is this guy doing?
What the...
Yeah, he saw me through his own smoke.
I was like, what?
It's the fucking classic controller bullshit.
They can do everything.
It's unbelievable.
It's that same Bangler that killed us last game.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm not gonna kill you, Pac.
Just once.
I thought you were gonna fly, so I push.
And you leave me.
That's true.
Ditto, Ditto, I got hit for 150.
Like, do you want me to die?
But I...
I...
I came to you, to call for you, but you leave me.
Yeah.
I got...
I got shot.
I'm sorry I got shot.
Like, what do I do?
Oh my God.
What are you, like...
Hey, hey, hey.
Ditto, Ditto...
Guys, maybe it's not... guys, I don't know, this team comp... I don't know, I think it's a team comp issue.
Okay, I hear one more team comp issue, I'm going to run and stole my life.
Oh, actually, I want you to tell me if we are going to fight or not fight, okay?
I feel like I was talking the entire time what we're doing.
What we're doing?
Yeah, I... listen.
I said we're going to third party this team while they were fighting and...
But you... but you... you tell me that you're going to poke them.
Yes, we poke them together and then we... when we find the right moment, we push them when they're fighting.
Yeah, but... but when... when is the right moment?
You didn't tell me.
When they're fighting.
But when?
When?
But I said they were fighting.
You have to say go now.
We have to fight now.
What do you want from me?
You're not listening.
It doesn't matter what I say.
You're not going to listen.
I'm listening.
But... just two, like... okay, we fight.
We fight.
I said everything I was doing, like what more can I do?
I can't.
I'm going to lose it.
I'm going to give up.
I'll play Blood.
I'll play Bloodhound.
I want to wash our back.
I want... I want to go with you.
Like how is it always my fault?
This is insane.
You are lagging.
We go now, but go what?
Go where?
Go now.
Go now, what do you mean go now?
Go me.
I want you to tell me when you do it.
I'll do it with this button.
You're saying that.
Seriously.
I don't know how to do it.
What do you mean you don't know?
I don't know where to go.
I'll go back, or I'll go forward, or right, left, where?
So, I'll go where?
Go now, but go where?
Where?
Are your ears okay?
They're okay.
I said it properly, left.
When?
I said come here, they're fighting.
Yeah, I went to you.
You were looking at the back.
Yeah, because there might be third party.
You know?
Third party.
We are third party.
We can be third party if we third party, you know?
Yeah, we can be third party.
Come here, you have to go.
Everyone, come here.
I thought you talked to doggy, you know?
Because you were with doggy, so I thought you were talking to doggy.
Because I told you that I was washing our bag.
So, if you want, you have to tell me.
My fault.
From now on, I'm going to tell everyone what to do at every given moment.
I'm going to use your name.
I'm going to tell you, come here, this guy, push this guy.
And I'm going to say, doggy come here, Dito come here, Dito push here, doggy push here, Dito throw nades, doggy throw nades, Dito shoot that guy, doggy shoot that guy, Dito res me, doggy throw me a drone.
Like, what am I supposed to do?
Think for you guys?
That's all we wanted.
No, no, just tell me.
Only tell me, okay?
Dito, we fight.
Everyone, we fight.
Only this.
I said, Dito, I said we're going to poke these guys.
We, as our team, one, two, three, three people.
But we can't be for two people.
Like you and doggy, can we be?
We as well.
Why would I say we if I meant only two people?
We, you and doggy.
We.
We is the whole team.
It's you, me and doggy.
Okay.
Maybe I'm the host.
When you say we, I will follow you, okay?
Yes, perfect.
Thank you.
Okay.
Alright, we solved the problem.
We solved the problem.
Now we go next game.
We.
I.
Watch our back.
We.
W, okay.
Okay.
Okay, listen, it's really simple.
If I say we go here, then the whole team go here.
If I say Dito watch back, then you watch back.
Okay.
If I say doggy go right, then doggy goes right.
But if I say we, that means all three of us go somewhere.
Okay.
Okay, easy?
Yes.
Yes, I got it.
I got it.
I understand.
Okay, so...
Do you understand anything?
Doki!
Yeah.
I wanna be Bloodhound.
Okay.
I'll be Bangor.
Yeah.
Again, we're changing comp.
Cause like we're figuring things out.
That's what you said.
Why?
What do we do?
Okay.
I'm Bloodhound.
It's okay.
Listen.
Uh-huh.
Listen, this is why scrims exist.
So we fix this problem.
You see?
We are fixing problems right now.
Okay?
Okay.
Why is my game trying to end itself?
What are our problems?
You mainly.
Because Asha said me.
Me?
What did I do?
I was just listening.
You were just starting shit.
I didn't even start anything this time.
You just started arguments in the team 24-7.
I didn't even start anything.
I didn't even start anything this time.
You see, Dito is confused and you're making me mad.
And then it's just your fault at the end of the day.
Like it's really...
At the end of the day...
We just need a Raven.
Everything is your fault.
We need a Raven.
We need a coach.
We don't need a fucking coach.
We need you to focus.
We need TSM Raven.
Doki, for the five games we played, you have been focused for three minutes max.
I was so focused last game.
I was with you the entire time.
That was 45 seconds that you were focused.
Yeah.
So it wasn't my fault this time.
It's nobody's fault.
Why does it have to be someone's fault?
Why do we have to give the fault to someone?
Why can't we just die and it was like unlucky?
Let's go next.
Because we're TSM.
That's what happened in TSM.
We are low paying TSM.
Yeah, TSM there's always somebody's fault in TSM.
I'm not ready for TSM.
But we'll be famous.
We're gonna be on top.
I wanna go back to scars.
What do you mean?
Okay.
I'm going back to when things were easier in life.
Guys, we're eighth place.
Guys, what happened to us?
We fell off just like TSM.
Why are you so focused on our placement?
You just wanna ruin our mood.
Guys, we're just like TSM.
You're just trying to ruin this team from the inside.
It's an inside job.
No, it's not.
I'm trying to motivate us to do better.
You have to be calm now, okay?
When you're already...
I'm calm.
Just be more cool.
Be more cool.
Okay, so what do you want me to do?
How do I get more calmer?
Breathe in.
Count to ten.
Okay.
It's like I have this fucking devil on my shoulder called Doki just trying to...
Dito, do you not listen to what this dumbass is asking me throughout the entire match?
What did I say?
Why do you need blue armor?
Why do you need this?
Why do you need that?
Blah blah blah blah.
Why?
She's asking questions from a crew.
She's just asking.
Why would I need blue armor?
Why?
Why would I need it?
Please tell me.
I understand what was the important part about having blue armor.
Why can you answer her properly?
Yeah, why can't you answer?
Hey!
She's just asking.
She just wanted to know.
I was just curious.
I wanted to expand my knowledge.
Because you're IGL and I look up to you.
I look up to you.
So I wanted to know more.
Yeah, she didn't know.
Yeah.
How did she not know?
Dito, how did she not know this?
Please tell me.
Please explain how this...
I was playing Tekken last week.
She hasn't been playing Apex Mobile Y.
So in one week she forgot what armor does in this video.
It happens sometimes.
Yeah, sometimes it happens.
Yeah.
Dito, I don't know if you're crazy like her or like you're fucking with me right now.
Team Sevier Monero.
With TSM.
I'm lagging in the air.
This is insane.
How many ping do you have?
180.
180?
It's not that laggy.
Yeah, but I'm also like lost.
I have lost.
Oh, like everyone is teleporting?
Yes, it's the same shit.
They're Dito-sting me because we won the first game.
Yeah, we peaked early guys.
Just like TSM.
Yeah, maybe that happened.
I think we won the first game and I've been lagging.
Coincidence?
I don't think so.
Yeah, we should like DDoS the other teams.
Yes.
Okay, I went playing Massive.
Oh hey, there's a bot.
I like bot.
Oh, I'm gonna do Repeater.
Actually, I should do Nemesis.
No.
Actually, no.
I want Carbine.
I'm gonna do Carbine.
You took 14 years of my life.
Who?
You.
Me?
I didn't argue with you this time.
You made me get into an argument with Dito which took 14 years of my life.
I made...
What did I do to that argument?
You instigated all the time.
I did not instigate this time.
I literally was just chilling.
I was minding my own business listening in.
I have Nemi...
Okay, but we learned something today.
What did we learn?
We means us.
Yeah.
You means you and me means me.
Wait, who's you?
Who is you?
Me or Doki?
Oh yeah, me or Ditto.
Yes, exactly.
So if I say you Doki or you Ditto, that means I'm talking to you.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I got it.
Okay.
See, look, we're fixing a communication problem before the tournament.
Yeah.
Basic English is now done.
Now we can move on.
Yeah.
Finally.
I am lagging so much.
It's insane.
I can't do anything.
Tell them to pause the game like ALGS so you can fix your internet.
No, this is a fucking planned attack from the inside.
They're Dittosing me.
Dittos them back.
Hit up destroyer.
Yeah, we're best friends.
Yeah, do you guys not know that chat?
RPR actually knows destroyer.
Yeah, we hang out.
And like, what's his name?
Tufi?
Yeah, Tufi.
Best buddy.
Tufi is EU, right?
Tufi is a fucking idiot.
That's what he is.
Do I want the Raven's charges ultimate or double the duration?
Duration of scan is more important.
Okay.
When you scan people, you can see them for a longer time.
You're going to need more time, right?
All right.
I need a fucking message now.
What?
Oh, it's going to be.
You know what?
Let's see.
We're all done for today.
Yay, oh my gosh.
Okay.
Can you like call... wait, can Zero be our coach?
Can Zero be our Raven?
No.
Why not?
I actually have a tournament this Saturday.
Right before we play, I have to play with Zero and Hardeki.
Yeah!
So like why can't Zero coach us?
Because he doesn't care.
He would care if you say it's...
Why would he care?
Because he's your friend.
Okay, and?
So friends should look out for each other.
Is that what friendship is about?
No.
Wait, then what's it about?
That's what they tell you in the kindergarten.
In real life, you're like the friendship is all about people...
having a use out of you.
The best way they can utilize you.
And once they no longer have a use for you, you're no longer friends.
Wait, but then like... then why can't we use Zero?
Because he's busy.
You don't know that.
He was free to play that...
I know that.
You don't know that.
You didn't ask.
Wait, oh, he's your friend with benefits!
He's your friend with benefits!
No, what the fuck are you on about?
That's what you said!
Is that what it meant?
No, that's not what it meant.
It meant that like...
you're only friends with people while you're interesting to them.
Once you stop being interested in them, they move on.
Just like everyone in life.
And then you just lose friends.
And you find more friends.
And you keep cycling them.
Because people move on.
There's people in front of us.
Fuck them.
Are they gonna move on?
Go.
They're like on this.
So they might take that.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, they're looking at us.
Why do you guys look at us?
105!
I got shot.
Wait, that bloodhound lost...
One more keg.
Wait, what the fuck is that guy doing?
I can't predict this.
This is insane.
63 flash.
62?
Last guy.
Last guy 1 HP.
I need to reload.
I have to reload.
Why are they smoking?
Vape Nation.
Flashed.
One flash.
Oh, no.
They're so lucky.
Oh, I need G.
Ace.
There's nobody behind us.
What if I zip on the roof and we just fucking go all out?
This is our last game.
Exactly.
We got balls deep.
Oh, yeah.
I shouldn't do that.
They're watching.
Yeah, I don't know if we should.
Yeah, but we bait them with the zip line.
Then I get an angle.
Headshot someone for 175 to the head.
And then we just destroy them.
Okay.
We're waiting for the destroy part.
I'm using my Ocha.
I'm charging my Sentinel.
Wait, there's people behind us.
Why are they behind us?
Yeah, there's a redeployed behind us.
88.
Why do they have purple?
They just had blue.
Now they have purple.
No, they avoid that purple.
There's people behind us redeploying, by the way.
Yeah, people behind us are almost dead.
Give me that head.
Give me the head.
What do we do?
Waiting for this team to like make a mistake and then murder them.
What if they don't make a mistake?
They will.
They always make mistakes.
Okay.
Fucking cheater.
Oh.
You call everyone cheater.
If he dies, he dies to a cheater.
Oh my god.
I can't see.
I can't see through the wall.
Wait, this guy is blue.
You can see through the wall then shoot them.
Yeah, shoot them.
What is that?
Oh my god.
Oh my leg.
What is that?
Can we shoot that?
88 purple.
Shoot it.
Do it.
88 purple cracked.
I need a heal.
Who's next?
I'm scared.
Come on guys.
Peek again.
Come on.
Oh my god.
This lag is insane.
I'm gonna go see if there's extra shield assist.
Oh, he's shooting through the wall.
He shoots me from through the wall.
Are they shooting?
No.
There's a gap in that wall.
Hit them Ben.
Hit them.
Kick out of the tournament.
Oh, right.
Yes.
88 cracked Bangalore.
I'm going to juice all of their meds until they can not.
I need to fucking find more shield cells.
I'm going to go back and explore.
Okay.
I can give you three.
Oh, nice.
Please do not explore the afterlife.
They stopped peeking.
All right.
In 10%, I'm going to give us a zip that's going to go down.
Okay.
Should we go near?
Yeah, sure.
I'm heading over.
We're here.
2%.
1%.
Okay.
You first.
We want to get ahead of them and...
Why are they smoking?
They're vape nation again.
Why are they shooting at us?
I don't know, but...
We want to get ahead of them and take control of the positioning and then gatekeep them out of the fucking zone.
They're smoking behind us.
We're going to...
I don't think anyone is going to come from behind us.
There is.
I don't think they're going to come to us.
Are they coming?
They're on the bridge.
Like the...
The bridge behind us.
The left bridge?
Yeah, see the lifeline package?
Is that a mobi?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, but there's two T's there.
Do I head to you?
And...
You guys can...
Someone can stay on the bridge there.
Okay, I'll stay.
I just want these guys not to come here.
I don't want them to fucking come to us.
They're racing.
They're racing behind us.
Oh, they are racing.
Yeah, yeah.
They're racing.
It is a mobi.
I thought it was...
I'm going to stay here then.
Well, that guy is going to...
One of them is going to be broke.
Here.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I'm looking.
I will stay with Doggy.
Yeah, you can stay with Doggy.
We're back on the bridge.
I can grapple back.
I'm going to scan.
What the fuck?
Yeah, what the fuck?
Yeah, I'm bullying the fuck out of this team.
Who fucking shot you?
Over here.
Over there.
War and Ping.
Well, I'll deal with them later.
Right now, I'm dealing with this team.
There's a team underneath that bridge.
Okay.
I'm going to go to you, Doggy.
Yeah.
Oh, they have crypto.
Just be ready.
Did they have crypto?
Okay, this team might push me.
Wait, there's a team in the cave too.
Yeah, that's fine.
They're not going to deal with us.
Just be ready to...
They almost tagged.
They almost changed.
If I get pushed here, be ready to fight this team.
I'm looking at the team in the cave.
Are they teaming?
Fucking cheaters.
Yeah.
These guys have to move.
So now be ready to get closer to me.
Be ready.
This team might push.
Okay.
I'm going to come over now.
I'm here.
Yeah, just stay on that side of the bridge.
And then this guy is going to come over.
Guys, I mean, we can even play from here.
All of us.
We just want these guys to fuck off.
Okay.
Go through the fucking tunnel.
Okay, over there.
One team over there.
On our right side.
Is it three people?
Yeah.
Three people.
Yeah, I see them.
They're crossing.
Yeah, they're going around.
Yeah.
Yeah, fuck them.
They went to the building.
We just want to keep that and this.
Yeah, these guys are coming out.
Okay.
We're here.
They're jumping out.
They are going to the tunnel I think.
No, they are pushing me.
Come here.
We are looking for you.
They smoked as well.
We killed these guys.
We have to.
We have no choice.
Use blood on ult.
They are close.
They needed.
They can pull back to the back side.
I need heal.
Just play in the middle of the bridge.
One guy.
Hit my ult.
Is that your ult?
I will climb up.
They are fighting each other over there.
I can scan in one.
I am scanning.
I didn't detect anyone.
I see a nerf.
They are crossing.
Blue armor.
I can't hit him because of this lag.
I am lagging like a bitch.
They are still over there.
Behind this rock.
That team is like whatever.
That team is literally just helping us.
They are here.
What do you need?
Try to save.
I can give you one.
I can give you some.
I have 180 right now.
I am running low on sniper ammo.
I got purple.
Wow.
They are just there.
I would hit them if they weren't teleporting.
I don't know where they are going.
They are smoking you.
They are smoking me.
They might go from right side.
I see right side.
There is a guy crawling.
Dead.
What?
He is there.
Yeah.
There is a guy crawling in the water.
What the fuck was he doing there?
My scan doesn't reach them.
Is this just a duo now?
I saw three over there.
This guy is crawling towards us.
Let's take on Bangalore.
Let's do that.
Can you scan them?
I don't reach it.
Can you get a little bit closer?
How?
Just a little bit.
To this raw or something.
I can scan here.
I will scan it.
Still not close enough.
It didn't reach it.
Yeah, it didn't reach.
There is a purple guy.
I think that is a new guy.
We got to go zone.
Okay.
Let me think about zone.
You guys are still holding there.
I can give you guys a zip when it is time to move.
That is in.
They are close to us.
Yeah, they are close to us right now.
I am backing up to you.
They are pushing.
It is okay.
We play from here and we hold them back.
Let me know when to scan.
They are going to go here and they are going to play those rocks.
We have to keep this rock.
Nobody turn.
This is so laggy.
I am so annoyed.
Be careful.
Those guys behind us can see us.
They are going to cross now.
We need to scan them.
11 seconds.
Scan in this direction.
It is open.
There is a team in that cave.
I am looking at.
I can see one.
One guy.
There is a shot from here.
Oh my god.
Careful.
They are shooting from left.
Just play on me.
Oh my god.
They are going to push us.
They are beaming me.
It is not good here.
There is no one alive in this lobby.
They can do whatever the fuck they want.
They are hard pushing.
Oh no.
I am lagging way too much.
Everyone is teleporting.
That is fine.
It is just a squint.
We had lagged debuff.
I am literally getting fucking...
fucking...
I am getting dedosed.
This is insane.
I was fine the entire time.
And all of a sudden everyone is teleporting.
How is this real?
This can't be real.
I think we need Wraith.
Now we need Wraith again.
Wow.
I don't know.
I feel like Patha and you just wasn't the right pick.
It is always the comp's fault.
It is never anything else.
Well if we had Wraith we could have portaled to a safer area.
Okay in the next game I pick Wraith.
We had Patha and we could have zipped on high ground.
If we had this we could have done that.
Did we even make that?
Isn't this the last game?
Yeah this is the last game.
It was LG.
Yeah it is 6 games.
It should be.
It is like a scrim.
It is okay guys.
We didn't show them our true strength.
Honestly if I wasn't lagging right there.
I would have killed that fucking team.
While it was crossing.
I had so many free shots I couldn't hit.
Because they are teleporting.
What if you lagged on the tournament?
Yeah what if you lagged on the tournament?
Then we are just going to lose.
I don't know what to tell you.
But like...
Why don't you just fix your internet?
How?
How would I do that?
If you know how please let me know.
Because I am trying.
Go to somebody's house.
Whose house am I going to go to?
Bring your PC over to somebody's house that has good internet.
No one has good internet here.
Then...
How do you play?
I don't.
I don't play Apex.
Because listen.
This game has the worst netcode on the planet.
That's not true.
Super Smash Bros exists.
That is true.
Me and Mande literally had 30% packet loss for a whole year in this game.
Just because Apex.
Everything else works perfectly fine.
But Apex is at 30% permanent packet loss.
It's only me and Mande.
No one else.
If it's just you two and there is a whole EU market.
But only you two have issues in EU.
Versus like 80 other EU players.
Then...
Obviously it wasn't just us.
A lot of people lagged in rank and shit.
But it's like specifically...
But you said it was just you two.
It's specifically certain hosts.
Certain ISPs don't work with this game.
Because...
I don't know.
Fuck this game.
It wouldn't be the ISPs fault.
So...
Let me...
If the ISP works in every single fucking game.
But it doesn't work in one game.
Is it really ISPs fault?
Or the game's fucking bullshit as netcode?
Maybe the ISP didn't update for Apex.
Because it was too new.
They don't need to update for no fucking game.
The game needs to update it's netcode for the ISPs.
But...
The ISP is weak.
Because Jesus Christ.
I don't fucking know.
I look like a specialist.
It's okay guys.
This is just a scrim guys.
We will...
Yeah.
And the tournament will do so.
It's like hey.
Your internet will be good on the tournament.
Yeah.
Just a bad day.
I'm gonna write a tweet longer.
If I get DDoSed on tournament.
It's going to be addressed to everyone in this tournament.
Fuck you motherfuckers for DDoSing me.
Fuck you.
Every single one of you.
Tell Hidels to ban them all.
I don't know which one it is.
But one of you motherfuckers.
It's you motherfucker.
Just keep shooting all your shots and eventually you'll hit.
If I just fucking blame everyone.
Someone's at fault.
Exactly.
Take a page from Doki's book.
Blame everyone.
Fuck yourself.
I had a great time guys.
Yeah it was just great.
I liked winning that one game.
Yeah.
That was such a good game.
Remember that time when we won that one game?
I didn't like when you cosplayed a statue.
That was not very cool.
That was the last time RPR had good internet.
It had to be that.
I also didn't like when you were instigating fights in the team.
How did I instigate?
I didn't even instigate jack shit.
I was just asking questions.
Yeah all I'm gonna say is watch your own one.
Okay.
Someone's gonna...
Listen why are we even arguing?
Someone's gonna fucking clip it.
There's gonna be a fucking YouTube clip.
Donkey making RPR lose his mind for the 57th time.
It's all fucking instigation bullshit while we're playing screams and I'm trying my ass off while you're fucking...
We're trying our asses off too.
Yap yap yap.
Why did you do that?
Yeah we're trying as well.
Why this?
Why that?
Blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah.
We're asking questions.
Oh we're not allowed to ask questions anymore.
Why are we not winning?
I mean it is a good question.
Two fucking questions allowed.
Two questions allowed.
I'm banning questions.
Then we'll never learn.
Good.
You don't need to learn you just need to follow.
It's not about learning it's about following.
You guys I had a great time.
I had a great time too.
Yeah I can't wait for Saturday.
When we have an even better time.
Yeah.
Yeah I'm so excited guys.
Yeah I can't wait to play with RPR on this day.
Yeah me too I can't wait to play with RPR on Saturday.
Positive mental attitude.
I am so excited for Saturday.
Yay TSM.
TSM.
Today is just a scream.
We don't take it serious.
Yeah screams are nothing.
Who the fuck cares about screams you know.
Yeah I mean look at our world.
None of us were serious at all.
Yeah none of us were serious.
Especially Doki.
No one cares about screams guys.
But I told you we win the first one.
And then we lose all the other ones.
We make them think they have something going on.
Yeah exactly.
We fucked them on the tournament day.
Yeah I agree.
I had a great time.
Did you have fun?
Did you have fun RPR?
Yeah it was great fun guys.
It was great.
That's great to know.
See RPR had a lot of fun guys.
Anyway if you want to donate to RPR's therapy fund.
You can super chat to me.
And I'll make sure the money goes to him guys.
Make sure it comes in the form of a gin and tonic.
Or I am not accepting your donation.
Well you don't have to accept the donation.
But I'll accept it.
Yeah farm me some more.
Yeah keep farming me.
That's what you said.
That's what Fred said.
Why is Dito laughing?
It's funny.
She's right.
Yeah my suffering is always funny.
We all suffer together.
Because it's friendship.
No we did not suffer together.
I suffered and you guys laughed.
We all suffered together.
I suffered because we didn't win.
We didn't win.
That's suffering.
Yeah but I suffered mental damage.
Yeah I had mental damage from losing.
We won a game.
From getting blamed by RPR.
Yeah we suffered mental damage because RPR blamed us.
Okay hold up.
First and foremost I was not even the one blaming.
What happened is you guys wanted to blame.
Like when I was being chill and I was saying.
Oh guys let's just focus on winning.
Why do we have to blame people.
You guys kept blaming everyone.
Why did you do that?
Why is this going?
What are you gonna do?
Keep your IGL.
Blame nation.
But we are TSM.
That's what it's about.
We were just asking.
Yeah we are asking too.
Not blaming.
We are just asking questions because we want to get better.
And now Harry gaslighting.
I'm gonna leave this column.
Before I leave my life.
Maybe you are too sleepy up here.
You are too sleepy to play this game.
It's okay.
You too.
This is like.
Being stabbed in the back by your own daughter.
No.
I didn't do anything.
Yeah.
We didn't do anything.
You shouldn't do anything.
Yes I always say.
Say to my chat that.
Let's pick our peer because he is a good player.
Yeah he is our hero.
Second to zero.
She is just lying.
I watch your stream.
All the time.
You never fucking said it.
I watched your stream.
I watched her the other day.
Talk to Japanese friend.
And the entire time she was talking about me.
She was talking about how scary I am.
And how bad of a person I am.
No I'm not.
I watched her and she told.
On her stream last week.
She was saying how much she admired you.
And how you are like her hero.
Yeah I said it's a hero.
Yeah.
It was on her last stream.
She streams so much I don't remember.
She streams a lot.
But I saw it.
Ditto's chat do you remember that time when she talked about like.
How much she admires our PR.
Ditto's chat.
See.
Show me the clip.
See the chat agrees.
Well they are not going to be able to find the clip right away.
It was so long ago.
It was like last week.
Yeah.
Do you realize that Ditto's title is literally.
Scream with Doki and one stupid RPR.
No it's not.
I don't see that.
Someone who respects someone.
Really write one stupid.
I don't say that.
Refresh your.
It says.
Doki and RPR.
My hero.
I have screenshots.
I have screenshots too.
You have photoshop that's not fair.
That's not photoshop.
What do you mean?
It's photoshop.
Now you are like gaslighting all of us.
Yeah.
Why?
Why is there RPR?
No.
It says.
Your title is literally RPR will die first.
No it's not.
Why did you see that?
Where did you see that?
I don't understand.
It says RPR will not die first.
I'm gonna go to bed.
My title is literally RPR will not die first.
And Ditto is like.
One hero RPR.
I'm gonna go to bed.
And I got homework for you guys.
You guys should really reconsider.
Your choices tonight.
Like really consider.
The words you are saying to me.
Really think about it.
Next time we play.
Really think about which words you are saying to me.
And what kind of damage and effect they could have on my mental health.
Going forward.
And that's what I'm gonna leave you with for tonight.
Thank you guys for watching.
Goodbye.
GG's thanks everybody.
Bye bye everyone.
Good night and goodbye.
Bye bye.
Ending screen now.